oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to the dope
as usual podcast we are here to talk
about drugs
problems life accomplishments and
everything in between i know i mix those
words up i know some of you guys are on
it
yeah i [ __ ] up but it's okay you get
the gist guys
this is episode 16. thank you so much
thank you so much for being here if you
were in the car
please drive safe we finally it finally
happened i saw it in the comments
i crashed my car hit a pole while
listening to your podcast
i got that [ __ ] in my dms oh [ __ ] yeah
please be [ __ ] safe out there
i i get it man i listen to podcasts
sometimes i'll be cracking the [ __ ] up
not paying attention
please pay attention please be safe we
don't want somebody to go hey
the last thing my friend saw or listened
was your voice then he crashed that's
it's not what we want if you're on the
road please be safe if you're at home
pay attention i've had multiple
i'm listening to the podcast i dropped
my bong on my laptop like [ __ ]
you guys need to be careful man i get it
it's not our fault directly but i don't
i
sounds bad sounds awful have you seen
these comments marty i haven't seen him
i've noticed you'd be very
cautious to the driver since the very
beginning always dude there'll be some
times i'll be listening to podcasts and
miss my [ __ ] exit
because i am laughing or not paying it's
just conversation man it happens so
if you're out there in the car please be
safe before we get into anything guys as
i said this is episode 16.
thank you very much for being here i am
[ __ ] hyped i woke up today without a
headache for the first time since early
february
i am so [ __ ] excited and a little bit
relieved
because now i can think i got on live
earlier i was hyped i was smiling like
don't feel like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
thanks all right thank you guys for
bearing with me
here's the episode here's the first
episode of the podcast besides the first
one
here's the first episode i have not had
a horrible sinus infection
so here we go guys i feel so much better
let's get right into some topics
the first thing i wrote down today is
bill gates is getting divorced
we talked about this a couple weeks ago
marty jeff bezos got divorced
richest man in the mayor and the world
now elon musk took the spot but bill
gates is one of the top five richest men
in the world getting divorced
holy [ __ ] if this was if this was the
80s and eddie murphy would still talk
half half that's one of my favorite
stand-up pieces
ever no half that's that's how i feel
like yo you have to give up
your money maybe that's why they got so
rich last year because they knew they
were divorcing their wives
it's logical it's a little bit logical
that seems logical on the wife's part
i mean they're rich no matter [ __ ]
what dude imagine being married to the
richest man on the planet
[ __ ] off put this away guys for everyone
out there that grew up with money
right now if you grew up and you you had
a pantry
first off you had a pantry you grew up
okay but if you grew up and you had a
pantry
and there was like fruit snacks and [ __ ]
in there and
and like more and more than just one off
like yo we bought a box of fruits next
eight months ago here's two left
now if you had [ __ ] lined up and there
was a grocery list you grew up okay
why did you grow up like that so much
yeah yeah yeah cool [ __ ] yeah see i
my friend nick moore first time i ever
saw that in my life i was in the ninth
grade i walked in
and he's like the drinks are in there i
go there's no drinks in here no no the
fridge in the garage went
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i was always jealous
of kids like that
i went in there and it was all what was
that like
have you ever seen bolt fishing party no
so when i opened the fridge just glow a
glow hit me like
you have multiple drank in here holy
[ __ ]
that's how april's parents house is yo
you want a drink go down to their
fridge in the basement you have some
options that's type my grandma grace the
super mexican one there was a bunch of
frozen meats and [ __ ] but in the garage
in the in the back
um my grandpa has this big shed because
they're all truck drivers so they work
on the truck and this giant
you know built-in grill it's like it's
like a warehouse yeah it's it's like
this just not brick walls it's like more
metal
but it's nice and uh in the fridge in
the freezer there was home run pies do
you know what home run pies are
no you know hand pies the little ones
that come in like the little moon pies
no no no like uh they're like cherry
um strawberry this is that oh yeah those
are ladies as [ __ ]
i'm addicted to those today and i know
they're bad for me but my grandma had
them and they're always in the freezer
so i would like
sneak pass get hella [ __ ] goat heads
in my feet trying to run to the [ __ ]
garage
get up oh god i missed the they're not
that good frozen
no they got the look the weird like
jelly apple jelly in the middle right
never say weird they never got into that
they got that delicious ass nectar
inside it
yeah so that's that's how uh
yo man our brains marty we started off
with bill gates now we're talking about
being rich
i'm talking about grandma anyway i see
home run pies so if you grew up with a
pantry and stuff in there
[ __ ] yeah my grandma grace is rich but
they act broke
and i was broke so i didn't it was weird
there's a rich man poor man though
because also when you cash in those food
stamps for the first time and you come
home and
fill that cupboard up you feel rich as
[ __ ]
see my mom always made me go to the car
right when we were paying for [ __ ] then
i found out that she was using food
stamps she was like embarrassed and [ __ ]
conniving no she was embarrassed she
didn't want me to like
no we're all only using food because my
mom always worked bro
even though she was a [ __ ] jerk
sometimes she always worked no matter
what always where even when she's on
drugs
she's a she's like my dad but yeah back
on the bill gates you rich [ __ ]
god could you imagine waking up and
going no my kids can make a volcano
today
they can make a volcano for their class
we have enough money to get cardboard
that's how when i made my volcano i was
like yo we are not going to buy [ __ ]
what am i going to do what do i do
it was diy but my mom's not gonna go to
the store and buy me [ __ ]
spend nine dollars on stuff [ __ ] no she
makes eight dollars an hour
[ __ ] off fourth grade ain't that
important uh
for real though so growing up rich must
have been sick so they're kids
i saw an article saying both the kids
get 10 ml a piece which is
cool 10 million dollars kids because
like as
as money to just go function but he's a
billionaire a hundred times over
so it's more like the jackie chan thing
you know the do you guys know about
jackie chan
do you know about jackie chan i know his
family
i know right yeah i know rumble in the
bronx um
jackie chan i love you so much but are
you ready
jackie chan gives his kid no money at
all
jackie chan is a millionaire a hundred
times over
and he will not give his kids money they
like live on their own do their own
thing they get no kind of money from him
and then i saw an article that jackie
chan's son got busted in china trying to
sell weed and growing weed at a trap
house which is
punishable by death in china he's not
dead
so maybe that's why jackie chan is like
you don't get [ __ ] you embarrass the
[ __ ] out of me
cuz dishonored his name introduced real
man jackie chan one of the
oh i brought this up last night i saw a
preview uh
i saw a preview for a movie i went and
here's a episode of here's a little
segment we used to call what's good
we need to bring it bring it back more
but this is the opposite this is called
what's trash okay
i went to the movies yes the other day
and i saw one of the worst movies i've
ever seen in my entire existence
with good actors it was just a stupid
[ __ ] movie it was called
profile garbage it was only webcam and
phone
footage and train footage
that's it stop turning soundtracks yo
great
[ __ ] actors garbage [ __ ] movie bro
the whole thing was typing
facebook this it was webcam between two
people the whole movie i thought i was
gonna get more than that
so garbage movie the reason i bring it
up because i saw a preview
and there's a new action asian star and
it's like
they finally smartened up like jackie
chan you do all your stunts you're the
man gently you're [ __ ] amazing both
you guys are unattractive
we got to get some good looking asian
dude in here to be a superstar and the
guy that god went
was in the office no that's that's a
male model
no this is the superstar the asian
superstar now
i see where you're going with this like
it was like some male models
doing flips all right i see it but it
looked like a badass movie
it looked like some uh the one with jet
li type [ __ ]
okay i missed that man where's the
action stars that whole genre just
it died out i think i mean rush hour was
the last one am i right
rush hour was [ __ ] funny yeah i'm
talking about like rumble in the bronx
[ __ ] people up i need some more of
that i don't know
i don't know why we got here i do know
that if you were to audit how most
celebrities treat their kids you
probably wouldn't be super happy with
what you find
my goal in life to do is get so rich
that my kids are spoiled pieces of [ __ ]
while being good people okay
that's what i mean like oh dad can i get
this i need to win the boat
yeah you're super nice and you're polite
i got you
oh you no no not you you're being an
[ __ ] you don't get [ __ ]
that's how it is like you get a range
rover when you're 16. [ __ ] yeah i want
my kids to be spoiled as [ __ ]
and still realize like you can't be a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
so that's the best thing it's it's tough
but you have to talk to your kids
like adults when they're young so they
understand why and what's going on and
explanations and
you get it don't ever my explanation to
my little brother do you see that bad
guy in the movie do you want to be him
no then don't do that like it's very
easy if this is a movie you're the bad
guy
do you want to be the bad guy that's it
that's how i think but i know it's a lot
more complicated than that i obviously
don't have any children but
yeah i know i i get the gist i raise my
[ __ ] little brother and [ __ ] so
he's cool he's monetized he's monetized
we talked about the last episode huh
yeah we did right yeah yeah
um we got onto that because bill gates
and jackie chan he gave himself 10
million dollars so
bill gates got divorced all right that
whole 19 minutes
bill gates is divorced let's go to the
next topic all right here we go
i got some notes today guys if you are
under [ __ ] 40 you know and you're
about to get
uh super sad and you know what i'm about
to bring up
i didn't know his name because i'm not
that guy charles gordon
dude the dad from beethoven died
damn beethoven's such a good series man
it was so good dude it truly was bo
wasn't chris penn
in beethoven man these obscure actors
are not
chris no chris penal sean penn's brother
yeah chris penn can you look up chris
penn dog movie
real quick with the magic of the
internet chris penn dog movie
oh yeah i was going to say reservoir
dogs of course oh yeah beethoven too
i was right i was right beethoven 2.
what i fed her yesterday dogs got to eat
every day and as he eats a sandwich i
remember thinking
isn't that that isn't the [ __ ]
from reservoir dogs that my mom watches
stop pouring that gun at my dad
[Laughter]
i love that ending dude oh
oh god dude and the beethoven's family
was the whitest family
of all time but that dog is baller
i love that dog so much yo
what happened to the dog movies
beethoven there's lassie there's cujo
there's homeward bound
yeah but predominantly dog sandlot was
more like
the beast and then you find out at the
end yeah quick little story
guys real fast i you guys know i love
the sandlot to the max i quote it if you
watch my story times i put clips in it
all the time
and reference everything i was at this
convention downtown well
a speaking convention like this cannabis
[ __ ] and
wait what time is it 13 minutes in so
we're taking ryan stickler's advice
10 guy nice to meet you yeah 10 guy
minute nice time apparently youtube
likes to watch the first 10 minutes to
make sure you're not talking about dicks
or what everything else and i'm going to
try to do the nice guy clock so shout
out to ryan sickler i'm going to gonna
lie to join now it's been 14 minutes
and now let's start talking about some
[ __ ] all right i just pictured some
some dude at youtube in a cubicle and
it's like are they talking about dicks
dick free 10 minutes in monetization
um can't we just get a fan at youtube
just like like start [ __ ] please
there's gotta be it's gotta be gotta be
um oh my god
oh here it goes what the [ __ ] were we
talking about
bring up the question now bring up the
fan question
every time i say what the [ __ ] are we
talking about guys i bring up a fan
question okay
marty can you please read the fan
question off who is it from today we got
zachary hill from patreon zachary hill
uh i met up with zachary hill
remember i told you the white dude from
oregon that's zachary hill
our dude from oregon um he we couldn't
show his face
i went and met up with him gave him some
stuff he's
he's ordered push trees since we started
writing orders writing orders and books
zachary hill what's up nice all right
what's his question
he says what got you to decide that la
was going to be where you want to live
and why from a business standpoint for
push trees much love and support as
always
all right this would be a quick answer
why did i decide to go
to lao what part of la i'm from merced
obviously it's
80 000 people it's not a very big town
the biggest building we have is hotel
tioga it's like three stories four
stories tall probably
that's the biggest the biggest building
in the town right so when me and rosie
decided to move to la
i said what's the busiest part of la we
thought probably downtown like
where pride by the convention stand in
the staples center and we said let's
move across the street
and we'll try it for a year and if it's
too busy too congested and i don't like
the people
we'll move because then i'll know this
is the busiest place in california
if i can handle it everywhere else is
fine two days in like oh this is fine i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't
nobody's bugging me and if they do i'll
just tell them get away from me it was
perfectly fine traffic sucks dick
and it's when donald trump was getting
elected president and they were doing
the anti-trump rallies
and the pro-trump rallies and the
meet-up spot was my parking lot
lit on the corner of flower and ninth
flower and olympic
the meetup corner i had a meeting put it
this way i had a meeting and it was
raining so i couldn't uh
walk but i couldn't get an uber because
there was hundreds of people outside my
building and i couldn't walk through the
crowd
or get stuck in the crowd so i missed my
meeting and it was two blocks away i
couldn't get a car i couldn't walk
it was the weirdest situation like me
and rosie woke up to
chanting chanting and yelling and i look
out and there's a hell of people with
signs
it's like my first couple weeks moving
here yeah [ __ ] was scary as [ __ ]
i didn't know what was happening i just
heard out my window if
no like i just mowed your [ __ ] um
so the reason we moved here is because
of that and we were here every other
week doing videos and stuff so
for push trees i mean a warehouse this
size in merced
is times four and a half cheaper so it's
not like we had to move here to do push
trees
but it definitely did help expand
everything being able to do more
meeting marty [ __ ] like that so zachary
hill from patreon thank you very much
another segment of what the [ __ ] was i
talking about
perfect and now marty what
the [ __ ] was i talking about before i
went into this
beethoven beethoven and then we went
where
into how white their family was and then
i said
no and i said let me tell you a quick
little piece oh people are gonna get so
pissed in the comments on youtube go
you never finished it but [ __ ]
okay don't remember dude oh it was about
the dude from reservoir dogs
all right reservoir dogs you watched
that [ __ ] ass movie
oh it's a [ __ ] ass movie now we're just
going back
oh man i'm sorry guys i completely
[ __ ] lost it because i said the ryan
sickler
nice guy that kind of goes with the idea
of what the [ __ ] was i talking about
okay yeah perfect you're right you're
right let's leave it because now i'm
just [ __ ] lost
damn it man all right
hey after we talked about mask remember
we talked about the mask and me inhaling
stories and shooting them out in the
last
podcast when i was up when we were
uploading the new podcast the mask was
the ad on the podcast
now free with ads youtube play that's
crazy yeah they're really paying
attention that's right
um so let's get on to some another topic
uh super sad beethoven diet
beethoven dad died that's lame that's
another piece of childhood gone
so here we go [ __ ] on to the next topic
i wrote some [ __ ] down today guys all
right
here we go i don't know who this rapper
is but i'm going to talk about it
because saw the video is
[ __ ] crazy there's a rapper named lil
reese please do not show
too much when you edit this because i
don't want people to get flagged for
bullet wounds and [ __ ] there's this
rapper named little breeze from what i
saw
i saw two articles one that he has a jug
deal gone wrong
second he was trying to rob somebody
with a friend try to rob a truck or
i don't know the facts and he might be
completely like in the right and he just
got shot
but i just see a video do you saw the
video yeah the guy little reese against
the wall this [ __ ] has a bullet
wound in his face
and he's like seizing he's it looks like
he's seizing right
he's like he sees the whole charging
thing was that he was caught between
he was coming through the wall in the
pole well the uh bike rack
so he's stuck and this pool's dripping
dripping dripping he's sideway it looks
like
um a war scene it was really sad
actually
then they turned the camera to the set
to the side and one of his homies
is covered in blood but he's got like a
darker blue jumpsuit with the you saw it
with the red and the yellow so you know
blood is not like bright red in the
movies that shit's dark as [ __ ]
sometimes
and he's got his whole cheek ripped open
and you can see where the bullet went in
and out you could see his cheek frayed
you can see his meat like
completely calm though but the thing
that makes me think like they're guilty
because
these the lady on the phone that's
recording is like you [ __ ] try
to rob me that's what the [ __ ] you get
talking [ __ ] to these men dying with
bullet wounds in their face
obviously something happened yeah i mean
and the thing is
the guy on the ground with the jumpsuit
he wasn't like
cussing at the [ __ ] like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
what because if you shoot me in the face
and i didn't do [ __ ] i'm gonna try to
bite your face off
i'm gonna come after you the whole time
but they didn't
so it kind of made it look like oh what
were you guys doing you just
let this woman talk [ __ ] as you're dying
on the floor
graphic graphic as [ __ ] i mean
[ __ ] if they do point five of the [ __ ]
they talk about in their music i mean
yeah it's right on power for what should
be going on so another
on the topic of what i wanted to talk
about is well we talked about a little
bit earlier before the podcast but
now i feel like it's glamorized getting
shot super glamorized
if you don't get shot you're not true
you're not real in rap right now
which is which might be the dumbest [ __ ]
i've ever [ __ ] heard in my life all
right
it's so stupid because during the
pandemic the one thing i really loved
hold on
shootings were down shootings were down
i didn't hear of any rappers getting
murked
it was very calm well i mean at least i
didn't
it was it was calm for a while and then
did you see the video that i can't say
his name
[ __ ] i'm sorry guys i don't really
listen let's
f something b f g b f b g duck or some
[ __ ] this guy in chicago got murked in
[ __ ] broad daylight
see the video fool's fools it was
terrible
it was so [ __ ] sad it was in chicago
too
broad daylight dude and
i just don't understand man i don't
understand the gang culture or not even
that
some of the rap culture it's like if you
rap you better be ready to fight and
[ __ ] shoot i don't understand where's
big sean
big sean ain't getting shot at big
sean's super nice like
you can be a successful super mainstream
rapper and not have to be hard
boondocks do you watch boondocks yeah
absolutely
um so boondocks does it perfect
gangstalicious
is episode is the best [ __ ] episode
ever and in the beginning the writer of
the show puts up a disclaimer
please don't run up on me in the club
they don't pay me enough to hire a
security crew
these are jokes this doesn't pertain to
anybody in particular pl and he got beat
up anyway i saw interviews
that he got beat up in a club because he
was making fun of rappers
and security to the max um so yeah
little rhys guy got shot in the [ __ ]
face it was super sad i just want to
bring it up because uh
it was in the news i saw like whoa that
[ __ ] was graphic
but question new question guys marty
do you remember rappers getting shot
when you were a kid not as often but do
you remember those times
yeah of course but there were legendary
moments in here yes in history
because it wasn't our show thank you
wasn't just world star [ __ ] new
uh somebody gets shot in chicago or like
it's sad man it wasn't just normal like
yeah it was just like a thing that
happens because so do you remember that
yeah what do you remember
yeah i mean it was like i was saying
earlier like
that shaped my whole childhood tupac
getting murdered was i was nine years
old just starting to become a no
awareness of
music and biggie and puffy and then
puffy's career took off and bad boy
rough riders and you're from over there
yeah but it was
the best time to be like born 86 to hit
96 as a 10 year old if you go back and
look at the music and the movies that
came out in 96 97
especially in hip hop it was just a
golden era so like my
the building blocks of my music were
just going down there
uh with all those early 90s albums the
bone thugs and
all the the bad boy and the the def jam
and the
rough riders and all that early 90s [ __ ]
i was obsessed with
but tupac getting killed like tupac was
my favorite rapper and i never even knew
him when he was alive
it was all post this you're a kid yeah i
was a little kid
but i mean it you guys i know marty's
not gonna say it but
i asked marty and he started touching on
this and earlier marty says when tupac
died
that's what he did when tupac died that
was it his face you went like this
because marty's daddy was a dad was a
jazz musician
rock yeah i thought he was a jazz
musician marty's dad was a jazz musician
and i'm like so you didn't listen to
anything else go nope it's all rap
maybe a little bit of r b i had boys
depend for a while right here and then
that's all you said earlier
we should have not talked about this
before the podcast yeah i did feel like
a disappointment because i didn't know
any other music besides just straight
hip hop still basically
yeah i know what you mean but it's okay
that's what you like that's what you
like
i heard what tupac got killed but i was
like tupac was
my [ __ ] though like up through the
machiavelli album all that he was my
all-time favorite
then jay-z kind of became my all-time
favorite dmx was up there for a long
time
then like the wave of 50 came like we
were talking and then
i idolized 50 but then that's when i was
really doing music and like i was
telling you that i almost signed a deal
with 50 and then it like
he was like 50 in game to me were like
the last kind of legends of that cloth
that were really cut from that that era
that were kind of still around in the
2000s
yeah um but then the biggest one to me
getting murdered was [ __ ] nipsy
hustle he was my all-time favorite
rapper that was so unexpected though
yeah like
you know bt awards and like gq and you
got me
now you're dead what the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was shocking
yeah in la yeah it was just so random
and so just necessary it would have
almost sat better with people i feel
like if it was like something that just
made sense like even some gang [ __ ] or
some i don't know but there's the
randomness and just how cold it was
so [ __ ] up bro and i just identify
like right now in this time that we're
in right now with this
i resonate with where he was at in that
moment and his like damn we're
like uh all this all these years we're
just about to get started
yeah and this [ __ ] has just he really
had that connection with his fans this
[ __ ] is just about to take off that
that's the whole tone of his music in
that time
yeah that's why that's dangerous since
he died the stamina
all i really listened to just because i
i i'm
in that vibe right now of like perfect
timing and
then just that entrepreneurial spirit
i'm not trying to hear an insider
[ __ ]
i want to listen to [ __ ] that fires me
up and gets me amped up to go crush it
yeah i like that yeah that's cool i just
listen to slipknot a lot
i don't know why just break that ted
let's break that
up screaming lately
death metal dudes ironically don't get
shot you know it's written in the name
[ __ ] dimebag daryl got murked on
stage
though that was sad as [ __ ] um
yeah i don't really remember rappers
getting shot often when i was a kid now
it's like
oh he got shot again [ __ ] dude
stop there's too much money out here if
you guys would be shooting the [ __ ] out
of each other i thought the pandemic was
going to change everyone's mind like i
said earlier
the second it started opening up a
little bit people getting shot
oh come on we almost [ __ ] could have
died last year as like as a world as
earth and now you guys are still
shooting each other [ __ ] off
keep that [ __ ] to yourself i don't know
man it's just so disappointing
seeing people still get mad at each
other like that so
[ __ ] dumb but you make yourself a
target i remember feeling like that when
i was doing music because
you're white from buffalo though of
course you're a [ __ ] target and
you're rapping like that and you're
getting successful
you stand out yeah for sure 100 it's
different because it's like you don't
know who knows you
you don't know who might not like you
they might not they might just be
annoyed by you
yep you might even know the [ __ ] they
are they're they're even aware of you
not at all yeah but they got all this
[ __ ] going on in their head
you know like that's like you don't know
about it yeah yeah of course
it's uh but when you were involved gangs
and street [ __ ] and retaliation and back
and forth
that's when you have to look hard yeah
and have to come off
no he snatched my ch i'll get it back
like you don't got insurance in your
[ __ ] chain
you know you can get insurance right
rappers you can get insurance on your
[ __ ] like a car
and if it gets stolen you get your money
back that's just wash your money
wash your drug money that way the [ __ ]
some people don't take advantage of the
opportunities presented to them
if you're a rapper and you change cats
don't go oh [ __ ] everything
[ __ ] like no now you just got 200 000
legal money
go buy a house [ __ ] out of here dude
some life insurance yeah who's the
[ __ ] live insurance so your parents
get paid [ __ ]
um so yes
so anyway i'm get off the murder murder
[ __ ] or
near death guys i got a small story
i see you smiling over there i got a
small story i told marty a piece of the
story before the podcast and then cut it
off because
i really really really wanted to see his
face when i told him this [ __ ] story
so as you guys know i know people i know
drug dealers i used to be a drug dealer
and it's not like
i'll ever tell you who they are or
what's going on but
i have friends that still sell drugs
right
here's the story guys that happened last
week and i'm gonna say it
because it's [ __ ] amazing
it makes me want to tell story times
about other people [ __ ] that's how
intense this [ __ ] is
are you ready so my friend called
facetimes me
as soon as he facetimes he just looks at
me like this and i go no
what happened and i could see
something's wrong like
oh no he goes bro go what
somebody bust his back window he was i
believe downtown
in a nice area and a nice apartment
complex
uh right outside of it he parked right
there like where you pay
someone bus his back window he had and
they took a box they stole a box out of
his car
or no a bag sorry not a box they stole a
bag out of his car
so they stole a bag out of his car
right he goes downstairs to get his
wheat
and goes oh my [ __ ] got my windows
shattered you know that situation the
first thing you think of
oh my god why did i leave that bag in
the car so in the bag there was a couple
pounds of wheat
and a bunch of miscellaneous black
market like edible vape [ __ ] like that
you know but hundreds of them hundreds
of edibles and vase and if you know
you're thinking like that's a lot
it's truly not a lot some people order a
hundred and you ship it to them but
like i said not me i don't [ __ ] sell
drugs anymore but
anyway he goes down there and starts
calculating that [ __ ] i just lost like
nine thousand dollars [ __ ]
and it's like it's horrible it's [ __ ]
whack
and he's telling me this and he goes but
about 30 minutes before i went
downstairs and got the rest so he had
more than 10 pounds in there and he took
the other like eight or nine out and
left a couple packs in there
so thank god he he got most of his weed
out right
still not fun he goes downstairs sees
the window goes
[ __ ] the security cameras all
that [ __ ] so he's like i'm gonna call
the cops my insurance [ __ ]
he's got a nice ass car so i mean first
off don't leave [ __ ] in your car you
should never leave [ __ ] in your car but
these fools were just busting windows
hoping to find something
anyway are you ready for how this turns
he calls the cops and they said make a
[ __ ] report on on the website they
don't even send anybody he's like make a
report on the website
damn so this is what happens he goes
upstairs he's all pissed off he smokes
weed comes downstairs and start cleaning
the glass up
when he goes downstairs he's walking up
to his car are you ready for this [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] ready martin this is the
part i left out he goes down someone put
this joint down he goes downstairs all
right
he's looking at his car and two dudes on
scooters
go by and go hey is that your car
you ready these two dudes proceed to
tell my homie
what happened they live at the building
right next door to the parking lot you
know it's like an open parking lot like
i said where you pay somebody
and you just park but he's right it's
like really nice apartment complexes
downtown
and there's a guard there so how the
[ __ ] they bust in windows the guard just
sits there and lets it happen [ __ ]
pulls in on that so they go hey
we live up there we saw this fool in a
[ __ ] car
breaking hella windows and just taking
[ __ ] out the car
we started screaming at him like yo
knock that [ __ ] off what the [ __ ]
we're gonna call the cops you know good
civilian [ __ ] like stop
bro stop busting windows what if they
don't got no money to pay for that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
so it wasn't just my homies car they got
broken to multiple cars in this parking
lot did
so guess what these are you ready marty
you ready i'm murdered these two dudes
that are on scooters are talking to my
friend letting him know what went down
right now
so he called the cops my friend called
the cops right went upstairs like i said
smoke weed came downstairs to clean the
glass that's when these guys rolled up
happened to roll up going back to their
apartment which is next door and they go
that's your car this is what happened so
they're yelling at the guy yelling at
the guy
these two dudes find it in their hearts
to run downstairs
get on two lime scooters or the scooters
that are outside that you put to your
phone
they get on two [ __ ] scooters and
chase the guy
there's three dudes in this car that are
bust one dude's busting a window
throwing [ __ ] in a car
and there's two dudes in the car like
one keep a lookout and the ones driving
so these dudes see the guys on the
scooter hey what the [ __ ]
assume that it's their car so they get
in the car and smash
take off at the parking lot and they
move out the way they'll get hit by a
[ __ ] car
turn around and it's downtown l.a you
weren't [ __ ] flying anywhere
you have to stop there's sometimes it's
blocked so
he said the two dudes are explaining and
my friends like they're just telling me
this [ __ ] story
these two dudes called the cops while on
the scooters
told the cops what's going on gave the
description the cops rolled up
minutes later and pulled these [ __ ]
dudes over in the car
so these guys are on scooters like yo
that's them that's them
heroes right you ready if you haven't
caught on yet
of what's happening you're not you're
not up to pace
because the second my friend said that i
just started smiling he's like what's
i'm like what do you mean why am i not
smiling you don't get it
i'm like they just got arrested with all
your weed in a pot
in a bag they are now arrested
with a felony in a bag they don't know
what they stole yet
they're just taking [ __ ] out of people's
car so when they get arrested
and they get pulled out by [ __ ] gun
point because they're running from the
cop
do you see what i'm saying running from
the cops breaking and entering uh
take take not breaking entering uh
breaking p property stealing
more than a a felony because they got
multiple things from cars so it must
have been over
uh 1500 bucks which is now a felony or
forty five hundred
and they have a bunch of black market
weed vapes
and [ __ ] edibles and pounds of weed
in a
bag what are they gonna say officer i
swear to god we
stole that bag bull [ __ ] these guys went
joyriding to steal from people and
caught a [ __ ]
felony caught a felony and a
distribution charge and tend to sell
because there's like multiple things
bagged up
if karma isn't [ __ ] bomb that's why i
smile and he goes
you're right i go you're you're not
happy that they can't spend the money
they're in jail right [ __ ] now if
they have any priors they just
caught another felony they just ruin
their lives by [ __ ] robbing you
isn't this great like do you don't feel
a little like
all right at least they're not spending
my money i i would feel like that
i'm not done not done guys this happened
last week right
this happened last week i've been taught
i've been like thinking about it all
week like how
bomb how bomb finally some jack kids get
[ __ ] because they don't like i said
they don't know what they stole they
don't know
they think it's like a laptop or some
[ __ ] they have no idea they just stole
prison time
what are the odds what if it was a body
or a head
they'd be [ __ ] anyway how are you
gonna deny that
when they get pulled out by gunpoint and
they go to the police station so what's
in the bag
i don't [ __ ] know we just stole it
yeah right so who's gonna fess up to oh
could you imagine that interrogation
room of
so what are these hundreds and hundreds
of [ __ ] edibles and pounds of weed
and
vaporizers like oh [ __ ] and could you
imagine their face
i swear to god officer it's not ours so
like i said there's more it's amazing
there's more
my friend calls me last night he goes
hey you're never gonna believe what
happened
i go what and he goes
the cops just called me because remember
he called the cops and made a report
all he said was somebody busted my
windows he didn't say someone stole a
bag of
drugs because why would he's going to
take the loss
it's gone it's [ __ ] gone just take
the loss you just reported it to his
insurance right
they call them and they go hey these
cops are just not doing their job are
you ready but you told me goes hey he's
on facetime telling me this and goes hey
in your car did anything get stolen no
they just broke my window okay because
um that night when we when we actually
arrested them
we found a bag and had multiple pounds
of marijuana and edibles and
and cartridges and my friend goes
nope no i didn't steal anything well
they're claiming that
they stole it from your car they
described your car your exact color
uh what window they broke and they're
saying the bag the plastic bag was or no
the uh it's like a duffel is that the
bag
was in your car and they stole it and we
pulled them over and they hadn't even
opened it
and my friend goes no i don't have no
idea what you're talking about yeah i
i didn't have anything just broke my
window so i reported it they go
okay well i mean it is a felony charge
so we just wanted to make sure
uh to clear this up before we started uh
pressing charges like
why even call are you sure are you sure
it wasn't your felony
come on if it was yours you gotta fess
up and help these guys out
why would they call they should just go
this is yours
this no you stole broke people's windows
it's over
anyway that's the story of my friend
that just happened i think it's [ __ ]
incredible
and you know what's really shitty though
is one day they're going to be in prison
and they're going to like yo this sounds
just like why you're in here
it's nobody's fault but theirs [ __ ] that
yeah of course if they didn't get robbed
they would have sold those packs sold
those edibles [ __ ] you you know what
you're doing robbing people
you deserve it but it's the first time
i've ever heard anything work out
i mean my friend did lose out big time
big time but
you can recover they can't
usually people like that get away with
that [ __ ] always always get away i've
never heard of anybody that i know have
gotten their [ __ ] taken got it back
well once but that's gang [ __ ]
that's different
i was telling you earlier about when i
got my cd player stolen
they on on the police report they put
larceny on my name
uh just mistakenly this is crazy so then
i had like i had to deal with that a
couple years later oh my god
um no there's a
smartie started telling me a story
before the podcast they go stop what
you're doing
stop what you're doing no more you you
now have to tell the story in the
podcast and i wrote in the notes like no
no no
i don't even want to know the end
because he started off with so [ __ ] this
guy's girlfriend
that's how you started it off so that's
why i really want to get into it
but let me uh let me get everybody like
a little
ready why uh ready why damn i'm burned
let me get everybody ready
the reason i brought he brought this up
is because back windows stolen
marty take it away
um well no we were talking about the cd
player being stolen and now
it made me think about it you started
well one time i [ __ ] this guy's
girlfriend
okay yeah you have to tell the backstory
the art of storytelling marty
what happened so all right i i just
moved to lackawanna
all right small little town this little
city bit little neighborhood on the
south side of buffalo
small ass ghetto little town i was brand
new there when i was like 16.
moved in and started meeting people
playing basketball and [ __ ]
the dude that became my best friend
energy started introducing me to people
he would go on to introduce me his
cousins became my best friends
period that are still my best friends
and
but he introduced me to this girl who
had a
kid she was probably 16 or 17 she had
like a two-year-old
we started hanging out with her he's you
know i'm playing basketball with these
kids learning the different
neighborhoods and [ __ ]
by way of him and [ __ ] but i started
kind of borderline dating this girl
coming to find out that she's actually
dating
my friend's friend who he had me like
driving this kid home from school you
knew him but you didn't know that was
great i didn't know it was his girl and
so then
he starts you know we're [ __ ] he's
taking me over into neighborhoods that
at that time i had no business even
being in because i
all i knew the only person i knew was
him you know so we're going over there
hanging out with this girl and [ __ ]
she's got a kid get a last situation
right now you live on her own no you're
going to hang out with this girl at her
house with her parents there she got a
kid damn they are not parenting
they are not [ __ ] on it man damn i
would
my daughter had no doors at that point
yeah but
um hold on anyway you said it very more
you said
you said it eloquently so i started he
started off with so one time i [ __ ]
this guy's girlfriend
you have to say it like that because
it's so much more all right i was
not that i even really knew what i was
doing and i was [ __ ] this dude's
girlfriend all right and then the moment
he actually in one of these times he
pulled up out he found the girl's car
pulled up in front of my mom's house
with all these boys
i'm not even knowing what's going on i'm
not even really knowing there she's
telling me yeah like
he's my ex we're not even together
that's nothing like i'm not even really
thinking about it
little to no he's all [ __ ] riled up
now because my boy that introduced us
is firing him is getting him all right
are you the only white guy
he's not this kid is like white and
puerto rican probably so the poor the
puerto ricans
are the white dudes and the in the
equation he's dating the girl that you
have in your mom's house at the point at
the time she's a black chick you said
black chick puerto rican white dude my
my boy intertwining all this is a black
dude
uh the guy that's the father of the kid
he yeah that dude is black too
that's your friend no no we'll call this
dude don
so don is my boy that i met when i first
moved there he's introducing me to all
these people
he's been he grew up there he knows all
these people he's he's a scumbag i don't
realize that
jesus christ yeah so anyway this dude
starts you know he he brings all his
boys they start causing ruckus in front
of my mom's house
my neighbor who i don't even know comes
out with a gun and like
tells these kids to get the [ __ ] out so
they were trying to beat your ass
because his girlfriend was in your house
yeah
and they saw her car outside your house
and went yeah that [ __ ]
we were upstairs in my room literally
with together i hear the ruckus going on
outside
oh my [ __ ] gift yeah i start
gathering up my [ __ ] i'm literally
putting my clothes on and [ __ ] and then
i look out the window and see that my
across the street neighbor come out with
a gun and these kids
have these kids yeah like at the ground
but like he was he was like a ball he
looked like he could have been in the
military too like a white dude like he
owned that [ __ ] house like
yeah he came out and they got scared and
ran away but it was super intense though
after that because
at that point i knew it was real no no
it was quick oh it was quick
oh yeah what'd she do sorry what did she
do she was just like she was kind of
freaking out a little bit
did she's like he's gonna shoot us
something she she said something about
him having a gun
okay so that's what i wanted to hear
yeah yeah but
like that's when i started really
feeling though like oh okay this is real
he's got a whole neighborhood of kids
also all the kids you didn't know that
he brought yeah yeah he had a whole he
was from a whole neighborhood
because he's in your little group of
homies though yeah but you didn't know
he was yeah i'm new still i'm new i'm
brand new to town here so i'm not really
knowing
something i don't really know yeah so
i'm just yeah i'm just you know
so i'm getting i'm new to this situation
these kids everybody in this town
[ __ ] grew up in the town
together you're the new kid yeah gotcha
yeah so
anyway she knew what was going on but
i knew i had people too that was like he
was he was thinking
damn this kid might get this kid might
get me shot oh
he was thinking the same thing got you
because once i realized once i
so the next this is how it all came this
whole story came about that next morning
i woke up in my [ __ ] cd player my cds
everything smashed out the windows are
out of my
car i just bought my car smashed out of
my mom's driveway and i
i didn't [ __ ] put two and two
together about who did it
until my boy years later told me that he
overheard homeboy talking about him
punch him in the face over it
the way marty put it earlier like i got
this friend he's a psychopath
yeah now he's like a co but he's a
[ __ ] psychopath and he overheard this
one kid
talking [ __ ] saying yeah one time i
busted that guy marty's [ __ ] bust all
his windows
and he goes oh that was you honey
[ __ ] socked him in the face
that's a friend yeah that's a good
friend man oh yeah so that's when you
found out
years later yeah but that the situation
got even more tense because the kid don
my
my dude that was kind of facilitating
this whole thing without me really
knowing that he just tried to start get
like setting me up for getting
for them to get yeah yeah like and
i found out about it because once like
once that situation happened where he
showed up at my mom's house i might i
think it was probably that day
i just i went to his neighborhood it's
called beth park in lackawanna
went there saw him hopped out the car he
walked up to the car
he got in the car he was [ __ ] furious
he's like you [ __ ] her
you [ __ ] i'm i was like nah
dude she said she doesn't have a
boyfriend that's when we started getting
into that eventually it came to that at
first out like he was so [ __ ] furious
yeah bigger than you no we were the same
size he was
as big as me okay but he was [ __ ]
furious i'm trying to i'm
borderline piecing together what the
[ __ ] going on at that point i was kind
of knowing what was going on
so we just we had this real [ __ ]
tense thing in the car and he's like you
know your boy's trying to set you up
right
you know he's like trying to he's he's
like yeah have him come down to the i
had met the basketball court you boys
come down there
so it's true homie that you made yeah so
me and the dude now are kind of like
oh we're i'm like he's telling me this
and all we kind of like got on that type
of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so you guys kind of like
kind of reconcile yeah a little bit a
little bit we both kind of got on the
same page
in that moment you guys are both getting
played yeah she's just like yeah no i'm
not banging marty and also like marty
that's not my boyfriend yeah
it was yeah me and her were kind of
light you know she had a kid like i said
i'm
i was new to this [ __ ] i'm like taking
you know yeah
anyway so probably within the same week
you know i stopped messing with this
girl immediately as soon as i realized
what type of [ __ ] was going on i was
playing college basketball and all kinds
of [ __ ] going on i'm like get the [ __ ]
out of here i do not need
i i was like i'm not i swore off
lackawanna girls in that moment damn
here
i only know like wanna cause [ __ ] yeah
it's just a tiny ass little
oh mention it yeah they mention it often
but anyway
then it the sad turn to the story is
like the
the the baby's father he was from
uh that he had grown up in that town he
was off in the military
that's your friend that was my friends
that like they had grown up with him the
dudes that became
my best friends in that town over the
years
they had grown up with him since kids
and in the same whole week that i'm
talking about he had come back from his
duty
and he was not happy about how [ __ ] was
going with her and this dude and [ __ ]
and she caught he caught him and
[ __ ] pulled him out of his car
whooped his ass in the street the kid
that was trying to set you the child
that was trying out was their boyfriend
beat you up yeah
because why because she was dating
somebody because he was the boyfriend
he was you know the baby daddy came home
and he didn't
he came home from the military he didn't
like how this dude was like treating his
babies
well they weren't together no more
though yeah oh so you're just like oh
you're being a piece of [ __ ] i'm a whoop
your ass yeah
i got you oh you're around my kid yeah
oh he put him in the hospital
yeah so and it was like that was a real
like damn
this situation is [ __ ] insane
i was like don't tell him i was begging
her guys because he's in the hospital
yeah so then uh shortly there after that
though
he he returned back to do his service
out here in california
and ended up getting in some incident
with the cops and he ended up getting
killed by the cops
while being an active military no [ __ ]
no
what shortly there is that is not common
no so it was probably less than a year
later
that that happened and then all through
rips everywhere like that that
shook like all my boys that they [ __ ]
has a [ __ ] military guy
he got murked by the cops yeah
where was he at oxnard california
yeah that's [ __ ] sad that that's all
i really know it was just the craziest
story how it
reminded me of it earlier just it's
funny how you say that like one thing
like yeah they stole the [ __ ] out of
this car it's like yeah
surprise and you talk it out loud but
yeah it was funny because me and the
dude that uh had broke my windows out
and [ __ ] we worked together afterwards
and i just i didn't know it he didn't i
didn't know that he's already been
punched in the field yeah
he knew nothing yeah so i look at marty
i was trying to be
a g i'm like what's up man we're in a
training class together don't even talk
about music real morning
i might bring up some [ __ ] some
artists that i stole yeah seriously
yeah that was my prize [ __ ]
possession too and i knew it i was so
cautious
you know when you had the cd players
back in the day you don't let people
ride in your car you don't let people
know you have it you take the faceplant
out all that [ __ ]
damn cena and merced it was very very
like
it's hot over here everyone's outside
it's not like over there where people
like inside at night because it's
freezing it's
it's everyone's outside it's hard to
steal people's [ __ ]
if there's people watching yeah so it
does happen
when you park on the street if you park
in a uh those like parkades not parkades
but um
apartment complexes that just have the
top covers those are easy to get
just uh get [ __ ] stolen out of the
the only time i've ever been like fully
ro first time i ever
got robbed i guess was my mom's car got
robbed
like they went in and stole everything
out of my mom's car
but my entire cd collection was in there
i was probably eight seven
i only had like 15 cds but they took my
[ __ ]
uh strawberry fields double disc beetles
thing i think it was a strawberry fields
i can't remember if it was is that even
the double disc can you look that up
strawberry fields forever double disc cd
the beatles
i want to say because i know it's just a
song i don't think it's an album
why am i mixing it i know i know it's a
song but for some reason i'm like
in the album in my head oh maybe
strawberry feels was
on it but it was a double disc beatles
cd
sergeant peppers sorry sergeant pepper
so sergeant pepper strawberry fields is
on them
all right i could be wrong but
first software releasing it yep as a
double disc yeah it just said that but
it was supposed to be released
but released as a double-sided a single
paul mccartney's penny lane
my [ __ ] brain ain't wrong but
they took it dude
they took it they took my mom's visor
that how the cds remember the slips you
put the cds in the visor
oh man they took that they took i think
it was like a led zeppelin one
and they had like five of the cds my mom
had given me that's how i started my cd
collection
they stole i remember when my mom said
no
somebody stole everything and i go no
wait
my cds 2 like i was like a kid like
[ __ ] and i remember thinking someone's
out there with my [ __ ] beatles cds
right now
you pieces of [ __ ] that's what i kept
thinking like you better
appreciate it my first cd ever had
please please me we have on tape
my sixth grade birthday i'm sixth grade
my sixth birthday at a park
that's some like no nobody was listening
i gotta i'm
just a hunch whoever stole that [ __ ] was
not listening to the beatles [ __ ] no
they just saw cds and snatched them dude
that was my first album that's on tape
i mean it's on video of me getting that
i have like missing [ __ ] fronts and
[ __ ] that was my first album i ever had
in my life
i remember we were going down seven
sixth street with my grandpa
and uh twist and shout came on and like
this
this is the song from ferris bueller
grandpa he goes yeah it's the beatles
you like it go
of course i like it ferris bueller's the
[ __ ] ferris bueller's what really got me
loving the beatles because i love that
song so much when he sang it in the
parade
and i'm like whoever sings this song is
just the coolest [ __ ] and that's
why i was like listen to james brown and
little anthony and [ __ ] as a kid as my
grandpa and
i'd be going to school and everybody's
like put on tony tony tony and go
what the [ __ ] is that so i didn't listen
to mainstream music until i was like 14
maybe 15.
i didn't even really like most of it
dude it was a weird
childhood growing up i didn't speak
spanish i was a [ __ ] fat kid i'm
super nice
i got long hair i'm really good at
basketball and sports
i'm really smart i'm in the crowd wins
class and i listen to [ __ ] oldies
only
so i'm over here getting ostracized at
school i remember people making fun of
me
all the [ __ ] time because me and the
teacher were the only people be like
oh yeah what's your favorite album like
all every teacher i had would always be
you like that tom's like yeah so what
else do you like huh oh you look oh yeah
the wall's really good like in the sixth
grade like the wall's great actually
and i do like dark side like all right
cool all right this kid is cool and
everybody just you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
no you don't like the game like not
until years later would i be into that
music
because i was always on this other [ __ ]
dude always on the doo-wop [ __ ]
double disc albums and
the greatest hits remember uh now that's
what i call
music those things of course but do you
remember the 70s
the 60s and they'd have an artist come
on with some new
lady that has no idea what the [ __ ]
she's talking about i think the 70s was
roger waters from the who
uh hello and then she's like so in 1975
and you can see him like
how much am i getting [ __ ] paid for
do this commercial right now but it was
like four hours long do you remember
those
yeah man that's how i memorized a lot of
uh
classic rock songs and names because i
have you know i mean i have to see it
when i saw it i memorized them so well
but yeah i don't know how we got onto
that so you're saying you didn't have a
lot of like lloyd banks and [ __ ] i've
never listened to late base before early
tupac in your cd binder that was
no no my mom did though my mom did she
looked she'd listen to tupac i got odb
and [ __ ] yeah that kind of i didn't know
odb was on the radio
i just knew that oh that's the guy from
wu-tang clan my mom really really loves
method man and odb
and she and the odb was with mariah
carey and [ __ ] doing this [ __ ]
all dope and i'm like yo this guy's this
guy's cool
but i didn't really listen to much i
write called hot 105 as mercedes like
rap and r b cool station you call it hey
i want to give like a friday night shout
out to my girlfriend
like i'm sorry i hit you [ __ ] like that
like
you know what i'm saying the love
station saturday night one to four
and uh i called in and go can you play
ozzy osbourne
uh uh crazy train and he goes we don't
play that kind of stuff here i go oh
okay and i hung up i was probably like
10 or 11. i'm thinking like
yo i don't belong in this town that's
hilarious it does not belong in this
[ __ ] town dude i didn't know anybody
else that liked the stuff i liked and
i don't know man that's really funny
though that your mom was on to the
hip-hop and you're all in like
no no she got me into all of that she
listened to that i'm saying the
only rap i was exposed to was tupac
odb ice cube nwa
heavy is that really it
fuji's a lot but that's not even really
oh no that's hip hop that's not rap to
me that's [ __ ]
sick ass hip hop musical numbers and
[ __ ]
yeah uh other than that no yeah just to
put a point in that the score is one of
the greatest albums all time
anybody who hasn't full time of all time
really yeah really i didn't know that
that shit's bomb
i love that album i love that album so
much give me that little chinese don't
give me that little chinese chicken wing
with no meat on it i just remember
thinking well this is my chinese thing
and i go wait what
what's happening as a kid i'm like
sounds like a samurai dude because i was
a very small kid listening like
so it's a chinese restaurant owner and
the rapper guy saying he wants more
chick and then just beat the [ __ ] out of
him
why is this in the [ __ ] rap battle i
remember thinking like
what is going on because i i grew up on
[ __ ] bruce lee that was my
first love of anybody like just
that was my [ __ ] that's why i was in
karate i would tell you how i stopped
karate
my karate teacher kept hitting my mom so
my mom never brought me back
that was it [ __ ] jerk
i didn't know but that yeah she's she's
loud that's that's some [ __ ]
but at the time i was like oh you [ __ ]
i just got my orange bell
you're kicking me out i was [ __ ]
heated dude she never explained things
to me what's the what's rox klondell's
wife's name she could have been him
rex quandell rex quando where's sound
from napoleon dynamite thank you
bet you're not going home to tina
tonight what do you say
i don't know that's what i'm picturing
as you say this [ __ ] i don't know but
the thing is
my karate teacher did have a mustache
like the pulling dynamite's
uncle how much did you throw this
football over that mountains he had a
mustache like that and kind of hair
like that have you seen the movie that's
my boy adam sandler andy sandberg
nah you know i love andy's adam sandler
right
yeah might be my top five adam sandler
movies are you telling me about this
yeah i've
is so [ __ ] funny bro
it is so ah
with your whole adam sandler being
explicit and r-rated and getting high
and drinking i'm [ __ ] with it i
love it so much it's so i just got i'm
watching it tonight
anyway that guy right there in the
beginning the the the
t the the boss the fat dude i can't
remember that's
his name is that name is is that tony
bennett the singer
anyway that's what my karate teacher
looked like that's all of this
was just to show you that's what my
karate teacher looked like just like
that dude the fat dude
that's it you look just like in the
mustache in the hair
this dude right here yeah that's pretty
much it i think it's tony bennett
a singer i can't remember but i could
i'm probably wrong i'm probably saying
the wrong name tony bennett's old as
[ __ ] i think
anyway that movie's so good marty you're
missing out on life you haven't seen it
i feel like that i'll watch that with
billy madison i'll entert
i'll put him right next to him damn well
that's a bold statement oh it's so
[ __ ] funny it's so [ __ ] fun it's
stupid too but
it's good man um why
why do we get on this topic i have no
idea
i'm so [ __ ] lost i ah we already did
that's
what the [ __ ] were we talking about so
i'm sorry guys maybe drink a little bit
of water or something
today guys we have a new product for you
and like we say me and marty say it all
the time
we're not just gonna take any
sponsorship if it's [ __ ] stupid and
it sucks and it doesn't work it's not
gonna be on here
so when this company actually contacted
us me and marty both looked at each
other like
this is [ __ ] perfect for everyone out
there no this is not three flowers it
doesn't [ __ ] smell like [ __ ] and
you're not from 1991.
so introducing blue man b-l-u-m-a-a-n
that's blue man this is a company
it's not just pomades for your hair
because you guys i read the [ __ ]
comments
i get hundreds of comments yo who's your
barber hey your hair's on point like
thanks
first off thanks guys also my hair is
only nice when we film guys other than
that
it looks it looks [ __ ] stupid as i
said i get a lot of questions on what do
you do how do you do your hair
guys honestly i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing i don't i don't know how to do
my hair so i try to do the most simplest
form if you're a regular dude i know a
lot of dudes use the
comb and blow dryer i'm fat i'm not
trying to blow dry my hair after get out
of the shower and just start sweating
again
how many of you went yup yup hella fools
at home said the same [ __ ] so guys this
is blue man this is not just
pomade uh hair clay it's not just that
it's actually has vit i know people it
has vitamins this has vitamins to help
keep your hair healthy
you know putting hair spray and all that
[ __ ] dries your [ __ ] hair out not
just
girls know this i know a lot of guys out
there know this too so i see this as an
important thing because i'm not going to
be young forever when i'm [ __ ] 50 i'm
like damn
i really should have done my hair more
when i was younger now it's falling out
so for the past year too i've really
been trying to take care of myself take
care of my hair i'm on camera i gotta
i have to upkeep this [ __ ] so guys this
is something that's gonna be really
[ __ ] awesome this is blue man so the
other night i used the deep oil
conditioner [ __ ] on my scalp it really
worked if you're like me guys i don't
know why
i use head and shoulders and my hair
still gets flaky sometimes so for all
the guys out there let's sum this up
this actually works it smells good it's
got dope ass packaging there's nothing
more that we need as guys so once again
guys go to blueman.com link in the
description use codeola for 10 off
back to the video so here we go i'm
gonna get into the next thing
real quick real fast guys next week's
episode all right the episode
after this episode all right
i don't know if anybody's i'm i'm sure
people have done this
but this is why i love the podcast i get
to expose you guys to worlds you never
saw or heard of
i'm very excited for this next episode
the next episode is going to be a guest
and i
love the movie interview with the
vampire and i think it's a great title
so this is going to be called interview
with the drug dealer and this is my old
connect
that's it when i was very very young
this is way more than nine years ago
i'm funking okay i bought hundreds of
pounds from this man
over the course of years i've bought
hundreds
and hundreds of pounds off this guy i
can't but begin to tell you
okay all right you guys i do think you
guys know that story time if you're a
new listener i do something called story
time on the dopaziola channel
and we're on episode 55 right i did
something called my dealers
i talked about all my dealers the reason
why i didn't talk about this guy
is because he was in prison
and i don't want to talk about a man in
jail
in prison talking about him on story
time do you see what i'm saying
that's why i never brought it up he's
been out of prison for years now pretty
much since i started story time but i
wasn't going to talk about it
i talked about this in my lives i'm
happy i'm smiling i'm always i'm like a
goofy [ __ ] but i will still get
shot in the chest
people will still shoot me just because
of some stupid [ __ ] i let
are you ready if i'm in a room with you
and this is 10 years ago and inten
and i looked at you and go hey all these
sales in a few years i'm going to tell
the world about it with a smile on my
face and i don't sell drugs so i'm okay
but you do sell drugs so you're [ __ ]
i can't do that to people that's why i
change names i change cities i change
i haven't told like 40 really solid
stories
because those people are alive actively
doing things or some are in prison
and if i add to those years or i get
anything
done to like i can't i can't i would not
be able to sleep knowing like
my friend was getting out and he's got
six more [ __ ] years because of me
because they
brought up a link to my youtube as
court evidence do you see what i'm
[ __ ] saying that's horrible i would
behold thank you that's horrible i'd
rather just erase the [ __ ] channel
and never do this again than get my
friends prison time over some [ __ ] i
said
you guys get it all right here we go so
guys um i've never talked about this guy
in the
in my dealer's story time the reason i
brought that up is because
i can't talk about everything all right
but it's been years i talked to him i
said yo
he watches it and he goes yeah this
shit's [ __ ] awesome and go hey
what's up with like interview with the
drug dealer i'll give you a [ __ ]
ski mask and we'll cover your all your
tattoos on your arms and we'll give you
gloves
just so nobody sees your skin color and
[ __ ] like we will
mask you up and i gave he's like all
right
i'll do it only if you give me a list of
questions first so i know what i have to
say and now i know what i
cause he will might slip up and start
saying some [ __ ] go to prison for
you see what i'm saying like he's he's
completely legitimate now he's got
[ __ ] kids
he's got little kids he's got a wife
he's doing the good [ __ ]
he doesn't sell drugs anymore so i don't
want to
hey i mean you're never going to know
but like hey
uh realtor didn't i see you on a podcast
you were in prison for selling drugs i
don't want to buy a house from you
anymore
so i can't like expose his ass and
ruin his other whole life so yeah guys
he decided
yes i will do it so interview with the
drug dealer is coming the very next
episode is interview the drug dealer
i'm so [ __ ] happy he told me a story
once
and as he's telling i'm going oh my
[ __ ] god he's like yo he was
i was gangbanging when i was a kid like
sounds like it
i could never do that to somebody oh my
[ __ ] god
i'm safe here right like i'm in your
house uh the first time i ever saw
crazy crazy crazy no no first time i
ever saw crazy guns was
at uh the magic mushroom story did i i
think i told you
i think i told that on story time i'm
pretty sure
i think it was coke store nah i don't
remember but anyway
my friend's dad like some [ __ ] crazy
dude had the tommy guns and sniper
rifles and he had a rocket launcher
it was pretty [ __ ] scary he was super
rich and i he had one room that was
just guns bullets big safes
i held a tommy gun like in a [ __ ]
mafia movie and as i was holding it i
think i've told the story i had to have
as i was holding it my shroom's kicked
in last episode title
i haven't told you about this as i was
holding i went
oh [ __ ] no i went here no no i'm done he
goes you don't want to see the bread i
go no no
no my mushrooms my mushrooms just kicked
in and i walked out the room because i
didn't want to have any death in my
hands
while i was on mushrooms like no get it
away from me but yeah i held a tommy gun
for the first time my life it was
[ __ ] cool um
but this guy that i've never alright so
interview the drug dealer i have for
everyone at the
on in the car and [ __ ] that can't see
well i guess it doesn't really matter
but this is when i realized i wasn't
[ __ ]
when i walked into this full spot and i
saw this man make
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
course of 15 minutes
i just blew my [ __ ] mind like i
wanted to like
shed a single tear and just start slow
clapping this man like
i would have never thought you had this
and that's what you just did
get the [ __ ] out of here and over the
course of years when i was younger
up north like seeing somebody make that
much money was so motivating when i was
doing that like wait i'm only buying 10
packs every couple days and
i just saw you move 200 pounds in my
face
like a box remember we talked about it
before box 100 pack like i've never seen
anybody sell that much weed in my entire
existence
it's [ __ ] incredible i've never seen
that my whole life
and that was constant every day so i
gave him a list of questions
questions i think like if i was at home
watching this and i was a fan of our
[ __ ]
and i was like hey drug dealer questions
what do you want to ask my homie my ex
drug dealer friend
and uh those are the questions i asked
all right
nice oh i gave him a list i'm intrigued
i don't know anything aside you know
nothing about him you've never met him
i've never shown him i've never shown
him on snapchat never shown his face
i've never shown his house never shown
anything never once but that's how
cautious i am around him you've stayed
in contact with him
yeah he's [ __ ] awesome he's not even
a drug dealer anymore it's [ __ ]
amazing
like i said like i could say he's
[ __ ] sells houses nobody's ever i
know it's him
yeah [ __ ] sells houses now he's
like a completely
reformed prisoner yeah dude he was
killing
it was so bomb i've never seen it it
wasn't
dan stinky as dan if you watch story
time it wasn't john
my dealer that went missing that's not
him it's not rob obviously he lived in
the [ __ ] apartment and it's not dan
stinky has dan that was blocking punches
i told you that story yeah none of these
guys i've never ever ever mentioned him
never
not even like i have breath toward him
ever
there's so many people like that like i
know i've i have personal friends that
just
like you're killing it black market
trapping it's
awesome i [ __ ] love seeing people
make
half house payments in five seconds it's
um
the amount of money out there is [ __ ]
incredible and it makes me so sad every
time because i can't touch it
i can't i can't i can't be doing this
[ __ ] and going to chill
can't do it so it's just like literally
money on the table gone
i've had some of these guys go you don't
do nothing at all no more
no i said bro
no not since like almost the end of 2013
[ __ ] i have not
no you're [ __ ] stupid that's they
always you're [ __ ]
stupid there's so much money on the
table i go
i know i can see it by your new house
your new
mansion tells me that you're doing
good i got it's crazy where i have so
many millionaire friends
and they're all just like in their 20s
and i love him they all do it so well
and they're all professional and they're
so
they're just good man they're just so
good at it they do it so
they do it right there's those few
dealers like drug dealers out there that
know what they're doing and it makes me
smile because like
oh you [ __ ] are killing it god
i wish i was so
weak i mean at one point you become
greedy though i mean god damn if you're
making that much money i mean [ __ ]
no it's just good business yeah i mean
if you could make and you end up going
to prison
well that that's there's a reason that
a lot of these people aren't out there
buying chains and out there buying this
and buying that they're just
you know how many guys out there have no
watch on with [ __ ] six million dollar
stash at their parents property
a lot a shitload and you know how many
people are in the car going
yep look back and there's a hundred pack
in the [ __ ] backseat there's
at least 10 people right now that just
did that please don't leave it in the
comments all right
please don't uh but yeah there's
it's everyday man i i love it i just do
the math so if you
remember last episode i do the math so
fast in my head i'm like
you mean 60 bands today goes bro every
every other day i'm doing them like
yeah [ __ ] yeah you're making 200 pounds
a week
you bastard it matt it just
stacks so fast i love it
that's how i feel like god i wish i was
a drug dealer still dude channeling some
whole different [ __ ] this episode
i know i'm just like [ __ ] start ripping
this like anthony anderson and [ __ ]
uh
what was it harold and kumar just makes
me want to burn this [ __ ] down
that's how i feel like god i love doing
this epis this
podcast [ __ ] come on nike pay us
two million dollars please something
[ __ ]
but i love it dude but i wouldn't risk
all that money for one day in prison
i can't now that if i was single oh my
god i would never have stopped
i'd be right now with two phones going
marty can we take a break every time i
look down no i got some fool trying to
get a box
but if i oh i just should have shivered
bro i would have bought
i would have you're not gonna [ __ ]
make it
i know stop oh god my whole bag's
twitching thinking about this money
stacking
i'm not even drunk usually i think like
that when i'm drunk
so what is he like he's selling boxes
sick you can watch him all the time oh
really legal he's a legal girl huh
is he flipping out the back door [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] when dudes like sex
outline like oh what are you wearing
awesome how many bucks did you say
[Laughter]
oh you taxed him always from new york
how i feel dude i swear to god every
time i talk to these guys
like i [ __ ] love you guys you keep me
going you're living vicarious yep
i am i really am but it's okay because
but
because i'm just trying to get legal
money a million dollars legal is better
than 10 million illegal
all [ __ ] day because at least i can
go buy property with it
and not just wrench it that's a fair
point i was wondering that too
yeah it's sad dude luckily i've never
had these problems oh it's the best
[ __ ] problem i've ever seen
it's crazy man there's a lot of money
out there damn we just went like 15
minutes talking about drugs and money
i'm sorry my bad my back is all shaking
though
damn just thinking about it yeah i feel
it like [ __ ] just
it's like those uh it's like in scarface
that scene where he's just i bought a
tiger
i go to the bank a lot i'm married
that scene where there's bringing money
to the bank yeah that's all it plays in
my head like [ __ ]
and nobody would ever know that's the
best part if nobody knows
you're doing it it's the best [ __ ]
part man
i mean if you're making that much money
how many people are you dealing with
like
how many four you got to remember
there's people on the other side of the
country that come over with 600 000 and
go
okay can i get 600 pounds if i get sick
if i you know what i mean because
a thousand a pound they're trying to get
outdoors or depths
it's real [ __ ] it's real and it's it's
nothing when you come back
and you made one point you made you got
a thousand you flipped it for two
i mean for a night for two for 12. 1200
right
what's what's what's 200 times
six hundred two oh what twelve what is
that
how much do you make in like 120 bands
yeah i think you make 120 bands off that
one
quick six hundred pounds if somebody
wants that i've seen people buy metric
tons
i get shit's real out there
[ __ ] are really pushing wait
mexican fools are
the mac's gonna do the outdoor heavy
heavy heavy
god i'm so glad i don't do this [ __ ] no
more
even though i just talked about how much
i missed it just thinking about the
hassle like
just thinking about the hassle like
never mind i just want to
give me a microphone just give me that
microphone man i'm over it
i like those rappers i don't have no mo
that's how i feel
but in the big twist irony i feel like
you're gonna
and the jump biggest twist irony weed's
gonna be legal across the country
dopaziola's gonna be the
poster boy for it
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] waiting for it let me be the
mario lopez weed please
seriously just say stuff at mike tyson's
fight
yeah guys um i don't remember what we're
talking about oh yeah interview with a
drug dealer god that was 48 minutes it's
a big intro for this dude
hello yo i can't wait for this episode
i can't [ __ ] wait and i even told him
like yo
because he he wants to start talking
like oh we can cut it we can cut it too
never mind we can cut
cut [ __ ] i just don't want him to slip
up i gotta still decide what name to
call him
meaning we're talking about michael
what's your name ricky bobby
hey so ricky bobby the first time you
ever sold a hundred pack how did you
feel
i remember the first time i sold an
ounce i just like
when all the power rangers come together
and film mega like what was his name
oh i'm in a hassle for not remembering
his name but anyway when all the powers
come together
that's how i felt when i first sold a
zip link
that guy's [ __ ] got taller like so
hyped so to sell the first box like he
did oh if i want to hear that
i want to hear that story because after
a while it's like you guys hold four of
those today
jesus christ
that's bomb they're from new york
oh my god you made three times as much
money as you would have made here good
[ __ ]
um let's get off this drug talk sorry
youtube i'm very very very sorry it's
all [ __ ] fictional all right it's all
fake get ready for next week's vlog get
ready for next fictional episode
it should start off and go none of this
is true yeah
[Music]
have you do your face yeah like uh
yeah that's all folks this is all fake
it's just fake as [ __ ] oh man that's my
[ __ ] al that's my alibi every time
that's [ __ ]
fake and if i'm ever sitting in the
[ __ ]
interrogation room like i'm an actor
like
yeah they're all made up man yeah they
really they don't [ __ ] with rappers even
like to the
nothing like they [ __ ] with you on
youtube if you really think about it
bro i think it's because i'm so
[ __ ] explicit when i talk
what's more explicit than a gangster rap
out i'm talking about murder
guns and packs and they're allowed to
have lean pouring but i can't
do anything it's okay i think it's
because a lot of people relate to our
[ __ ] and if
i'm just gonna i don't know i'm just
gonna leave it there i ain't trying to
even kill him you can leave it at that
i'll just i sent you that screenshot the
other day meanwhile on youtube
it was like marty sent me a screenshot
on youtube of this [ __ ] boy it says
smoking out of the pookie at 30 at 13
and it had this [ __ ] little boy
hitting chris
out of a pookie pipe in a bathroom yet
it had 18
000 views and it was up for three years
for three [ __ ] years
it got reported at least once
what the [ __ ] but i can't [ __ ] i
can't roll cross joints
[Laughter]
here we go interview with the dr what
time we at
117 117 perfect timing are you guys
ready
i'd like to do this formula with me and
marty where we talk about some stuff you
know talk about more stuff maybe we
could do a little story
talk about some [ __ ] and then i
ended with a story all right
so this story this story
about my neck for it dorian you ready
this story i'm about to tell you is one
of the
well i think it might be the only time
yeah it's only time i got extorted by
the cop oh it has to be the only time
i've gotten stored i had extorted
textbook
extorted by the police one time and let
me tell you how it happened
and i think the reason i get out of
these situations because i look like
fabian alamo
clark kent i i think it is it's the
hi sir oh man hello let me hold the door
for you
hey i think that's what it is it's this
radio voice and the smile and this
haircut that makes me go
what was it in uh don't be menace in
south central while you're drinking the
juice in the hood
where the white guy comes in and he's
robbing the whole store but the uh
the store owners are only looking at uh
what was his name uh
marlon wayans marlin and yeah yeah he's
only looking at them
oh you buy you break your buy and the
[ __ ] fool is
shooting oh he robs oh you dropped a
dollar
remember that [ __ ] the white guy thanks
that is uh how i look to people i think
and i just go
was that a 10 pack on his shoulder it
couldn't have been
and i leave um so here we go
i'm so back to what i said i'm so glad i
don't sell drugs anymore
for everybody out there thinking like oh
this one wants to quit no no
no no no i wouldn't make any money
everybody and their mom sells weed now
no we game is dead so i'm glad i don't
first off but i'm so glad i don't
because i have to look over my shoulder
and worry about oh there's a cop behind
me now there's a cop behind me
i'm just like rub my blades i don't give
a [ __ ]
there's no packs in here it's great i
had two scales in my car the other day
because i was doing a video where
weighing out weed and i thought and
their cop was right behind me i had a
joint lit and i thought
who [ __ ] cares there's no weed in
here to weigh
i ain't selling [ __ ] because i was the
fear like [ __ ] there's a scale in here i
always kept the scale in separate parts
of my car
took the batteries out just they always
get you with the scale that's the
ultimate
bad i never kept bags just kept pizza me
me and ed's cups
so i put eights and little uh cheese and
pepper cups
with the lids anyway here we go guys off
topic hella bad my bad extorted by the
cops this is the only time it's ever
happened i believe
let's get going oh yeah and then i said
this is why i get away with it and i
went into that whole spiel here we go
everybody in the car get ready for car
talking get ready for time passing if
you're about
30 minutes away by the time you know it
you're gonna be at your destination
please don't crash please be careful
make sure you're not speeding look down
maybe even set your [ __ ] cruise
control
because uh we're about to be chilling
here we go this took place i believe
2014 i think
i can't remember um i cannot remember
and this goes back to
you don't sell weed no more like i know
but i just always i always
just god there's so many opportunities
where i'm like how what
do you need [ __ ] okay never mind
um so here we go
i was me and rosie used to be friends
with these two people it was a couple
and they were when i moved here they
were some of my best friends or pieces
of [ __ ]
they were some of my best friends they
tried to play us once i still love the
people even though i called them pieces
right now
i still love them but they try to play
me very weirdly
so i do not [ __ ] with them in any way
shape or form [ __ ] them
even though i miss those people you know
what i mean like that situation that
sucks yeah it
[ __ ] sucks it sucks a lot those are
the fools that got me stopped eating
processed food and then i eventually
just like
started like looking towards veggie v
being vegetarian [ __ ]
because of them they're cool as [ __ ] but
the pizza [ __ ]
anyway here we go so
they asked us if we can go to colorado
with them because
let's just call them
mark and now let's let's do a better
name
i was going to say mark and anthony now
say mark anthony but i forgot there's a
guy and a girl
okay let's call him lisa and
john all right john and lisa here we go
there we go no bart and lisa so bart and
lisa here we go
bart is the husband obviously and this
is my really good friend and lisa is
also a really good friend and rosie and
her good friend
it's just great they're cool ass
[ __ ] right they were [ __ ] them
they were here we go this is
like 2014 i believe maybe even a little
so earlier than that i can't remember
we are going to go to colorado because
she is getting an award
for some cannabis thing i don't remember
what it was i can't i can't remember
what he what the event was
but um i got [ __ ] faced with the mayor
of denver which is kind of cool and um
here we go here goes they said hey
we live in merced we didn't even leave
in our new house our big dope house yet
we used to live in the push trees
that's how long ago it was had been over
seven eight years ago
and um here i know i keep going here we
go but for real
here we go forever in the car this is
where it's gonna get started let's go
they say can you come to colorado with
us we'll make a trip out of it go uh
[ __ ] yeah
let's go so
they say can you drive from merced to la
and from la we'll start driving to
colorado and i go
yeah and they said we'll pass through
vegas we'll stop we'll hang out with
some people we'll smoke weed
and we'll go so i am happy i have never
ever ever taken a road trip like that
besides to portland back when my dad
[ __ ] smuggled my ass out of
california and uh
so i say yes and i go
i should probably like get a 10 pack
from somebody remember i didn't sell
wheat anymore i was just
like if i'm going to colorado around
weed people and i say
oh it's california weed i can make a
thousand dollars a pack
and i thought ten thousand dollars
sounds bomb on a road trip
cool like my rent was 600 at the time
and like i said i was struggling to make
it because i stopped selling weed
so i thought oh [ __ ] even though i
stopped let's get let's get this going
i'm gonna do it
so i hit my friend up for a 10 pack and
i ended up not taking it because i
didn't really like the weed and i
thought you know what
no no sorry sorry sorry sorry i didn't i
was gonna get more than 10 pack
i got the 10 no no no sorry sorry i know
i'm back tracking and [ __ ]
i didn't get the 10 10 pack this is a
different time i didn't get the 10 pack
my homies i didn't like the wheat that's
what it was i didn't like the weed i
said never mind
because it was way too expensive and i
want to go to colorado with weed that i
wasn't confident in going check that
[ __ ] out i need weed that sells itself
that's the [ __ ] i needed and i didn't
have it it was like i had to go well you
know i'll drop it a dollar or two
dollar two means a point or two means a
hundred bucks sorry
i'll drop it a hundred dollars or two i
don't want to have to do that route so
i said never mind i come to la meet our
two friends we get in their car
rosie and i and with bart and lisa we
get in the car
we drive to las vegas go to las vegas
it's
probably two in the morning we're in las
vegas right
real cool nah it's probably 12 like
midnight
we get hash we get weed we get edibles
we're smoking
i don't have a 10 pack on me and i kept
telling them like
god i wish i could have got a [ __ ] i
tried to get it in vegas too
i tried to find somebody with like a
good enough time back in vegas
just so like i knew i could flip it in
colorado even though it wasn't so weird
no more it was
in my blood like i knew i could [ __ ]
make money when i was gone on vacation
so i said [ __ ] i'm gonna try
so we're leaving vegas no 10 pack i
didn't get a 10-pack but i brought two
ounces i brought like
seven or eight jars of eighths of weed
you know what i'm saying like it was
before like all weed was branded
it was just jars of wheat like you know
i mean like see-through jars with lids
uh medicine bottles with that fat one
pretty ass purple mug
we all done that [ __ ] i had like six or
seven jars i had my backpack
i had some edibles and pens in there
nothing like selling
you could tell that was smoking it was
under two zips but that way
it was under two ounces total but i had
i had like one and a half ounces in a
bag and the rest of the little jars and
eights i had were
equal to about two ounces right so about
about 56 grams
and the reason i'm breaking that math
down to you because it makes a lot of
difference
in about five minutes so we leave las
vegas
lisa gets in the back with rosie and
they are falling asleep
bart and i i'm in the passenger seat
bart's driving
bart looks like a hippie long hair right
long hair white dude
looks like a hippie so we're driving
we make it through the sun's coming up
man
i just remember this the sun's coming up
it's bomb
the sun's coming up we're in utah okay
we're in utah i've never been to utah
i've never seen plateaus it all looks
like [ __ ] road runner
it was cool man i've never and i was
smoking a joint we had the
the the top of the they rented a
mercedes suv
like not a g-wagon but like you know the
suvs he had the sunroof cracks there was
like cold air coming in
the sun was just coming up in the desert
the desert's cold as [ __ ] at night
i don't know if you guys know that it is
death cold it's not hot at all at night
so this the air is coming in imagine the
air is coming in i'm looking around the
sun's coming up in the distance just
like plateaus and just
crazy red rocks everywhere i've never
seen this in my entire life
smoking a joint i look over and i go hey
slow down i just tell my friend i tell
bart slow down
he goes we're fine man slow down man it
says 65 you were going 75
i know because he brought like a bunch
of edibles to give to somebody over
there
he brought like 30 edibles to give to
somebody
nothing huge just edible no packs no
nothing just edibles
so say slow down i even said like twice
slow down do you guys we're fine we're
fine he's got the joint
he's just like we're listening to music
and he's doing this [ __ ]
he's having a great fun it's a it was a
good ass mood like
it was the best 40 minutes right
the sun's fully up sun's up over the
mountain
in the distance i see a smoke right if
you've ever been
out in like plateaus and planes you
could see a mountain that mountain might
be 13
[ __ ] miles away it might be 50 miles
away you cannot tell
in the desert like that so way out in
the distance i see like a mountain
and then i see there's some red rock
plateau [ __ ] and then i just see smoke
like black smoke but i can see it's
coming from
like a little town you guys know what
i'm saying just imagine we're on the
freeway
the sun's out way off in the distance
there's just like a little town
what you can't even see you can see
those buildings you couldn't tell what
kind of building it was that's how far
it was in the distance right
there's black smoke and i go oh that
place looks scary
just randomly right i said that to him
go that place looks scary goes oh
[ __ ] that because it's in the middle of
the desert
we're driving you know what i mean like
oh who lives out there type of
weirdo [ __ ] hills have eyes that's
what we're thinking
but that place looks scary i just and i
bring that up because it makes sense
all right sorry i know i'm all over the
place but i'm just trying to imagine it
all
i've already told him to slow down twice
okay
we're coming around a corner it says 65
miles an hour we're coming around a
corner like on a drop
of part of the mountain so we're coming
down and it's
two or three lanes on each side it's a
big like freeway
but it's on the side of like a hill
in the desert and you know what i'm
saying so
we come around this corner and the sec i
mean the second we come around the
corner and downhill
the sign drops 15 miles an hour
some speed trap [ __ ] it's at 65 i
think and it dropped to 50
within seconds around the corner
impossible
to know it drops unless you're from
there so
of course there's a cop there right but
this cop is in the fast lane shoulder
turned the opposite way facing oncoming
traffic
with his speed uh speed r his speed
radar [ __ ]
this full speed trapping people at like
eight in the morning 7 30 in the [ __ ]
morning sun just came up
he's sitting there speed trapping us we
come around the corner
all i see is the sign and go oh dropped
and then i see the cop go
[ __ ] joint's lit joint is lit
in utah oh my god this story pisses me
the [ __ ] off
sorry i just got so irritated right now
here we go
i go [ __ ] and he goes oh [ __ ] and then
nip
he's on the opposite he's on the wrong
side of the road
flipped toward us it was some [ __ ]
he was
it was dangerous where he was parked he
speak he got us a second we passed him
whoop
lights go on he flips around my homie
rolls his windows down
and i just don't give him the joint give
me the joint give me joy and i start
like putting it out in the [ __ ]
ashtray and i put the ashtray
like in the center console without no no
i put the ashtray like
[ __ ] where did i put i no i think i just
left it there i just put the jar oh i
put the joint in the can that's right he
had a can
i put it on the ashtray and threw it in
the can just so it would go out
and we're sitting there yeah yeah that's
right it's right i put in the can
and you know when you're trying to stall
a cop to slow down you don't get over
right away you
gradually slow down and merge so you can
air your car
out we had the windows our two windows
down and the
sunroof completely down right when we
got lit up
because we knew that was it like [ __ ]
he's gonna smell it we're in utah you
cannot smoke weed in [ __ ] utah that's
what i know you can have eight wives you
can't [ __ ] smoke weed over there
so here damn my joints out
so we're getting pulled over guys we're
getting pulled over and i tell him [ __ ]
and right when he gets out the car go
[ __ ] look at his hat
you know cops a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
when they got that big ass hat
i saw that big ass chp hat and go oh
no oh god here we go
he started walking over he's walking
over remember the sun is just coming up
and there's cars passing us guys it's
[ __ ] freezing outside but i don't
really get cold
but i know it's really cold so i like
when he comes up i'm doing this like
hi officer like because the windows are
down so i'm trying to play it to like
innocence like
oh this guy's just cold talk hey yeah
sorry we're speeding like i was trying
to play it up i wasn't cold but i was
just doing this [ __ ] like
i don't have a jacket sorry and i was
trying to like
i do it all the time i do it all the
time and i do this a lot when i'm in the
car
i do that when me and rosie are smoking
jointly i'll do that
so when the cop passed like oh there's a
tourist i do it all the [ __ ] time
oh [ __ ] maybe i should have said that
anyway here we go
cop pulls up goes to my side because
obviously we pulled over on like a
freeway he's not gonna
cops don't go into the lane they go on
the [ __ ] passenger side always right
they don't get hit by a car
i'm looking at him and that time i go
rosie and lisa are asleep
and i kind of look back and they're
waking up to a cop
i was just on the side you know what i'm
saying they're waking up to a [ __ ]
cop right there
and he's talking to us and the one of
the first thing goes hey gentlemen how
are you doing you're going a little fast
there
and my friend has a mouth and he goes oh
i'm so sorry you know the signs dropped
real fast and
and he's like from the east coast so
he's kind of like it kind of sounds rude
and i go yeah sorry officer that it
dropped so fast he goes
you know it's illegal to smoke marijuana
in the state of california all right
he's like
you know it's illegal to uh have
marijuana in the state of utah this is
not california it's california plates
obviously
so that's that's what he said you know
it's illegal to have marijuana in this
so i'm like [ __ ] a second he said it i
knew you know those moments when you're
like
there is no getting saved on this one
it's done we're getting searched
we're going to jail it's it's this is
the one you know when you're getting
pulled over you go
that was for me and you know it and you
get that ticket after you leave you go
that's the feeling of
i knew it that's the feeling i had
and we go oh yeah officer sorry go so
how much weeds in the car we go
there's no weed in the car i have like
maybe a couple jars in my bag
and he goes don't think i'm stupid man
like i can smell the weed
how much weeds in the car you know it's
illegal he's saying you know it's
illegal in the state of utah to possess
marijuana it's not california
like all right bro in my hand i'm like
okay [ __ ] you already said that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you and he just says he says it again
and my friends is like
oh sorry officer you know we're in las
vegas and we were smoking marijuana in
the car because we didn't
want to smoke in our hotel so you know
kind of smells in here and he goes
no that's fresh marijuana so i can smell
my and he would smell my bag
he could smell my backpack with a zip
and the j of course
um my friend also had about two ounces
in jars weed and then
like those medicine bottles but it was
in the center console i forgot about the
weed he had i just know my weed like
[ __ ] here we go i'm gonna go to jail in
another state
like [ __ ] man so
so he goes you step out of the car and i
go okay
and my friend just starts going officer
please and by the time rosie and lisa
are awake
in the back seat and he goes officer
please and he goes
this is not an option you need to step
out of the car and i go sir it's okay
we'll get out of the car my friend just
goes no
don't get out of the car like sir come
on man we weren't doing anything wrong
let us go and i look at my friend like
get your [ __ ] ass out the [ __ ] car
don't get my ass whoop that's all i kept
thinking like
they're ripping us out the car whether
you get out or they rip you out
i look to the officer like if you back
up i will gladly get out of the car like
i was not having like your skin color
tells you you could say that or
something
just because you're a white dude and
he's why he's not gonna be like hey
camaraderie
[ __ ] this mexican kid no [ __ ] he's
looking at you like oh you're
questioning me like this is not an
option he said it twice
this is not an option he had that hat
that [ __ ] hat dude
and he goes officer please like my wife
she's sick and blah blah blah i'm like
why are you bringing that up like she
hasn't like a disease and [ __ ] i'm like
you know what the [ __ ] does that have to
do with this and he's just trying to
throw everything he can
and he goes one more time if i have to
ask you again i'm going to rip you out
of the car
and i told my friend bart get the [ __ ]
out and i told him like get the
[ __ ] out of the car he goes officer
officer come on he said it again and i
just lo i looked at him like
you're gonna get me [ __ ] and you're
oh my god i'm gonna beat your [ __ ]
ass like i can't believe you're not
cooperating
it's eight in the morning almost we're
in the desert
this guy's got a gun no get the [ __ ] out
of the car
uh by that time there was already
another two cars like a suv pulled up
and another like squad car like
highway patrolman car because he was
like he was in the highway trauma car
and uh so there's three cars and there's
a cop in the back of our car now and a
cop on the other side of the back i
didn't even see him walk
up i just saw in the review mirror as
he's like the next time i'm going to rip
you out of the car
and i look back oh there's more get the
[ __ ] out of the car
and he he doesn't say anything and the
cop starts to like
walk around the car my friend opened the
door all right all right he got out of
the car
he finally listened when the cop was
about to walk around the [ __ ] car
and snatch him out i step out the car
rosie and lisa get out of the car we are
now on the side of the freeway
right like it's like we're right by the
car and there's rocks and there's still
snow on the ground like it's freezing
and i'm doing this number
like trying to cover up to make it look
like i'm cold and i'm just like
where he goes are you getting a jack i'm
like it's packed up man it's
it's okay it's okay go ahead and search
i was just trying to i was trying to
play to the
uh maybe they are okay type of thing
right like that's what i tried to play
the innocence man i really did like i
wasn't cold don't give a [ __ ]
i was just trying to make him laugh this
guy's cold let's hurry up maybe they
won't search the whole car for like
he's freezing i was trying i don't know
marty i was just going oh my god
that's all i yeah that's all my [ __ ]
it's either that or the emergency
bathroom there's
nothing bro there's nothing so he told
us he tells us stand over there
we stand about 20 yards away from the
front of our own
rental car and they start searching it
starts searching and he goes his
backpack that's all he says he's in the
car goes who's backpack i go
mine that's all i think of mine
all right cool puts it on the hood and
starts just dumping all my weed out on
the hood and go
oh my god the cars are going by slow
it's early in the morning there's not a
lot but when cars go by they're like
damn these fools are just there's a
little jars all over the [ __ ] in front
of our own car
so he's putting everything on the hood
he got my pen like some [ __ ]
edibles man i'm going to color
whether or not i go to jail i am
weedless
for the rest of this trip i am [ __ ]
weedless so
here it goes guys one of the cops starts
coming over and taking our names
right and he goes oh hollywood huh
fancy i'm like yo is this is this going
to turn into some deliverance
hick [ __ ] he spelled weight
wrong he spelled hollywood wrong and i
think he said license i think
we got our paperwork and go this fool
can't spell at all and
as the other fatter dude came over and
he's taking our name he goes
what do you guys do homie from hollywood
it's the nicest car i've ever seen
that's what he said nicest car i ever
seen it's like a 40 000
[ __ ] mercedes suv like a regular ass
[ __ ]
soccer mom suv nicest car i ever seen
they just right when you say that go oh
this is not gonna turn out good
i can see it i can feel it this is
[ __ ] over with
so what happens the search in the car
and as he gets to the truck cause he's
hyped he's [ __ ] he thinks he got a drug
dealer when he opens my backpack
and he goes to the trunk and my friend
has like seven duffel bags
and only one of them has edibles the
rest are clothes but they're all the
same duffel bag
he was a drug dealer at the time so he
buy duffel bags in bulk okay
so it's like the same blue duffel bag
with a [ __ ] strap and
as soon as you open the trunk he looks
at his guy and goes come over here
because he thought he just got [ __ ]
us transporting right
he thinks he just got us like oh [ __ ]
here's 50 pounds [ __ ] yeah good morning
he opens it and just closed hella pushed
trees close too like just close close
he's putting it out
he's looking at the guy he's like all
right and he starts putting everything
on the ground dumping our whole [ __ ]
car like he could see he got
aggravated he's just he's pissed he's
throwing [ __ ] on the ground
and he finally goes there it is that's
what he says there it is
and it was the edible bag that's it some
[ __ ] edibles goes huh
what's in here huh my friend's like oh
yeah sir they were in his
wife's bag lisa's bag so he was about to
charge her and go so this is your bag
yeah it's my bags like all right put
your hands behind your back and he comes
over no no no
no no no she's sick she can't go to jail
i'm like this doesn't [ __ ]
matter you broke the law stupid how are
you going to keep
asking like no she can't go to jail
i was appalled by my homie like shut the
[ __ ] up we're going to jail all right
and he took the blame for his like no no
there it's my it's mine i packed a bag
it's my edibles nope mine
it's mine and he took the blame for her
chance behind your back and i go oh
no the resting [ __ ] bar and i went
like that
like i looked at rosie like [ __ ] i'm
going to [ __ ] jail too
but guess who didn't go to jail this guy
me because i was polite and he goes hey
you were cooperative and everything i'm
just going to write you up
[ __ ] yeah let's go your soul was about
might be 120 grams like oh
wait that i had in my bag goes yeah how
much like maybe a quarter pound maybe a
half pound i go
officer there is an ounce and a half in
those bags he goes
are you sure sir i can eyeball that
right now and tell you that's
that's probably about 38 grams and i go
the rest of the bottles maybe makes up
14 grams we're about
hitting two zips right now under my
california legal limit and he goes
it's not california i know sir but i'm
telling you that's why i know how much
it is because i have a card
this is back when call this before prop
2 uh prop d
or whatever it is and prop whatever the
[ __ ] prop
dumb [ __ ] we're in that [ __ ] the trap
[ __ ] up prop 215 was a [ __ ] this is
still prop 215
and he goes oh okay so i'm gonna write
you he wrote me for 65 grams even though
i told him 56 he wrote me up for 65.
i think he might have been illiterate or
dyslexic because he couldn't spell
anything and he wrote 65 instead of 56.
so anyway i got charged for that right
and um
i did not go to jail then he said so
we're going to come to the station you
can bail him out and we're like okay
cool [ __ ] yeah okay we're gonna go bail
him out
we he already got bart's in the [ __ ]
in the car in the back of the cop car
i'm just like yo
this is [ __ ] 12 hours ago i was in
[ __ ] la getting high oh
my god you know i mean like what if what
a change of events man
trash so let me get on the story a
little faster i feel like i'm dragging
this [ __ ] out sorry
so um excuse me
rosie and lisa don't have a license at
all rosie used to be a racer
like a little [ __ ] honda racer when
she was young and she got her license
suspended multiple times for racing
so they took it away for years so she
just got it back recently so at the time
rosie had no license
and lisa has an ailment that does not
allow her to physically drive a car
so they say hey you thomas
was the last time you smoked two and i
said sir maybe about one in the morning
and i said it like that without doing
the math and it was already eight he
goes
okay good all right all right you can
give me sobriety test right then and
there he goes all right follow my finger
and go
okay all right i did the fingertips like
you passed
it's like stand on one leg and i want
you to squat down and go wait
a squat down on one leg like sir i don't
even know if i'm strong enough to do
that like are you
you [ __ ] gymnast and he and he did
the uh one leg
30 seconds touch my nose do this and he
goes alright you're good here's the keys
he gave me the key so we can drive the
mercedes rental to pick
up bart out of jail and he goes
you're gonna have to come with us come
with us to the station and go where is
he goes maybe about an hour hour and 45.
what a gap hour to hour 45
[ __ ] just say an hour and a half what
like sometimes you get there fast
[ __ ] you and i go wait it's how far and
i'm already stressing because it's
oh wait we're not going to get to
colorado to what oh my god we wasted a
whole [ __ ] day you know i'm thinking
like
let's get the past this [ __ ] he's
arrested we got a ticket i have a
[ __ ] court date because of my [ __ ]
recharge i'm like you know this is some
[ __ ]
and he goes you see that smoke out there
that's the town i go
no way no walking away so when i met
when i that's why i brought it up
earlier the town up wanted out with the
smoke
that's the town um i think it was called
orange grove orange veil
orange dale one of those words
orangedale orangevale something utah
orangevale some [ __ ] anyway
we're driving behind this cop we're
driving behind this cop and he pulls off
the freeway to a dirt road and i go
no [ __ ] way because bart has the best
convincing skills so that's why he kept
he would not stop in the car he was like
come on officer come on
because he's good at that and he pulled
over and i go
did he convince him to let him go like i
thought like you know bart
you're a [ __ ] grand champion if you
just got this officer
to [ __ ] let you go because he pulled
off the freeway
no it was just an hour on a dirt road
it was up into the cut it was dirt slash
asphalt but a lot of dirt we go
and about 45 minutes in i'm like are we
getting killed out here
you know like is this is this real
are we really arrested because i was
nervous we were going out to the middle
of nowhere
past up we passed the town from
footloose it's just all broken down
there's nothing left it looks like
[ __ ] the bad parts of detroit you see
on on tv
like that but not burned down just
abandoned
there's a gas station there's one
grocery store
which is reasonable for a small town but
it's a grocery store and the restaurant
and together that cool [ __ ] those dust a
little dozen it was
sad it was sad it made me think like uh
remember that movie two won foo thanks
for everything
where uh wesley snipes and patrick
swayze played chicks with john guzamo
yeah
that that was the exact town that's the
kind of town where they go
that's the kind of place we ended up so
we go by we see like the broken sign
welcome to like oh
no it's resident evil [ __ ] we follow uh
right to the road that leaves the police
station
we talked to the officer and he's got
him and go hey um how long is going to
take
it maybe take about an hour go ahead and
you know get some they were so [ __ ]
nice once we got to town
uh the officer in the back he's like oh
yeah just get some food just hang out
we'll give you a call we have your
number you can come bail him out talk to
the bail bond and he was very like
cool very cool we go to the grocery
store we are stupid just before i
stopped eating meat and [ __ ]
i ate chicken la cordon bleu from a
[ __ ]
deli counter in the middle of utah and
it was
bomb as the [ __ ] we all three
it was eight or nine in the morning or
like 10 in the morning by the time we
got there and rosie has like spaghetti
and my friend has a chicken in the
corner and i'm look i'm eating away
why are we eating risking our lives
eating this [ __ ] out here
because it was weird man it felt the
vibe and that town was
off anyway three you know
four hours later they call us they said
an hour hour and a half four hours later
so the whole time we don't know what the
charges
they they tell us as charges and they
tell us which bail bonds this work gets
some this is where the extortion comes
are you [ __ ] ready for this
this is some [ __ ] these guys got it
made out there they did they do this to
people all the time see california plate
pull them over or something they got
something right
so call the bail bondsman
tom super nice guy tom piece of [ __ ]
you sound cool you start telling the
charges he tells us we tell him how much
the bail is and he goes okay you have to
put up this much money and we look at
each other like
i don't i just said i stopped selling
weed i didn't have that money
i was going to get that 10-pack from it
to me and go sell it and come back and
pay my friend
and
he goes the bill is 3 500 and go
what if we like just pay a portion of it
he goes well
if you pay a portion of it he's not
going to be able to get out until monday
it was a friday
we go no we have a convention tomorrow
we we cannot
he has to come with us we can't and he
goes well you're gonna have to come up
with that money
and we go oh my god okay tom we'll call
you back called another place
oh tom uh recommend us to another place
that might be able to help us
that's what he said they're all in
cahoots two bail bondsmen in a town of
five people
they're in cahoots right with the cops
too because they're just extorting
[ __ ]
so we called another place we tell him
situation he goes so
this is what i can do if you can get
anybody in town to vouch for your
character
i'll do it i'll let him leave and then
you can pay us on monday because we
couldn't go to a bank
we couldn't get money out or we couldn't
get that amount of money out of a
[ __ ] atm in the middle of nowhere
there was no banks we couldn't leave do
you see what you see how this is going
right
and all she and he goes so if you get
anybody to vouch for your character
we're like we're not from here oh that's
too bad then he said it as an [ __ ]
like
if you know any of the eight people i
know i guess they'll let you go
oh that's your mom like no [ __ ] you
know we're not from here
[ __ ] you the way he said it was so
condescending like
well i mean if you just happen to know
the mayor i can do it for you he was
joking basically as a [ __ ] and we go
we don't have the money he goes
what else you got that's what he said
the bail bondsman what else he got
that's what he said to us like no no no
this is not legal
what else you got what eight what year
is it
[ __ ] you and my friends that i have my
engagement ring we'll bring it down here
i'll see what it looks like maybe i'll
get it appraised it might work out
that's what he [ __ ] said to us
her engage got engaged like or they got
married i got my wedding ring
oh what's it look like okay what kind of
ring is it like he was just asking all
the questions like hey
that's what he was trying to do like
just hook us and we told him
no like we're not gonna just give you
the ring and have to come back and get
it like a pawn shop
the guy was just trying to what else you
got i don't know if i'm able to help you
out we called tom then he goes so
you have a ring and clown [ __ ] no this
[ __ ] full tom was cool and now he's a
piece of [ __ ]
they were trying to get anything we had
a value in the car anything we had it
was like some bulls there was some
[ __ ]
so i end up draining what i had in the
account
because i first off i didn't think i
could access the money and i did
that's the only way we got him out it
took like nine hours we were there for
nine hours total
got the money out got him out they still
took [ __ ] two hours to let him out as
we were waiting in the waiting room like
he's coming out right now two hours
later
oh it was the worst dude and tom walked
us out and we're just shaking tom say
like thank you so much tom and
bart's like yo tom you're the man i
[ __ ] appreciate you yuri really night
we get in the car
and bar just starts going [ __ ] that
[ __ ] tom that piece of [ __ ] set
this all up i could hear him talking
like he could hear them talking in
cahoots like shakes shot a wedding ring
like
oh my [ __ ] god they were getting us
something i forgot to mention
as we got off in the dirt road and i
realized oh we're driving to that town
guess who opens the center console and
finds all my friends weed
the guy couldn't figure out how to open
the center console or something wow yeah
there's two buttons you had to press
them or something
i don't know it's like it was it was it
was kind of confusing but he left
maybe two and a half ounces in the
middle center console
so we weren't weedless on the way to
colorado right when we got into the
[ __ ] hotel
that we got there in colorado we all
just looked at each other like
this is some [ __ ] let's get high
[ __ ]
this but yeah dude we got him out like
nine [ __ ] hours later we left as the
sun was going down
almost we get back on the road and i
look back like i
never come back this piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] town that chicken was good as
[ __ ] though
and i walked and we drove off and as you
get back on the freeway wherever we
started look back you see the smoke like
this bad omen over here [ __ ] this place
they had they made my friend they they
said he has a fly back for his court
dates
three times they try to give him a
warrant and they try to give him a year
and a half in jail oh i didn't tell you
what they charged him with oh my god i'm
sorry guys everybody on
the road the cop goes i don't really
know how to measure edibles
he goes it's like 15 pounds so i'm just
gonna say you got 15 pounds of weed
that's what the [ __ ] he said even though
there could have been two ounces total
spread across those hounds in those that
batch i'm gonna just charge you 15
pounds a weed and we'll deal with this
later
so he wrote down on his thing
distributing on his [ __ ] on his
charge
that's why it was so expensive for us to
get him out sorry dude my [ __ ]
brain's everywhere i'm over here just
imagining this whole thing
so we got extorted i had to pay six
hundred and eighty bucks
no court date no misdemeanor in france
gave me a fraction
that cop helped me out because i was
being polite that's exactly what
happened
god damn 680 bucks edit bait should have
slowed down
i told him twice bro hey slow down whoa
we're fine with the joint
and as we're getting pulled over i
looked at him like
you [ __ ] this is it i'm going to
jail now
but uh that's the story of getting
extorted by police 15 pounds and hold up
and
no no no no no he could prove milligrams
and [ __ ] like
that the cop was so [ __ ] oblivious
man he was
truly stupid truly a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
uh his hat told me that right off the
bat you gave me a dick
guys i don't know why that took half an
hour to tell but it really
like i just replayed that whole thing in
my head right now i'm just so irritated
i'm sweating
i'm sweating i'm so irritated dude look
at this [ __ ]
that cop was a [ __ ] [ __ ] could you
imagine being such a piece of [ __ ]
that you do that then again they
probably
was the football captain was like i'm
staying
home town just stayed there and now he's
a dick
there's 50 people in the town he runs
the rural
area he's just that guy it's it's chew
on food thanks for everything
that's exactly how i felt when i walked
in there like yo
everyone's looking out the window at us
i know it
i only saw a few streets it wasn't it
was very small
that [ __ ] is so creepy like when you
drive to vegas you go through needles
and
oh needles yeah it's all just abandoned
[ __ ] trailers and [ __ ] off in the
distance
yeah you ever see that that town xxyz
cccx
that's just [ __ ] stupid um sorry guys
i know i got off on a
long long story
that's how we got extorted by the cops
yeah dude see this is why story time is
great all those times i was like
then this [ __ ] i cut those out
in story time so it's faster
oh this is half an hour story for one
story usually been 14 minutes
because i'm over here that this one and
this [ __ ] but yeah that's what
happened man bart and lisa
um never went to jail that was [ __ ]
hilarious i could not believe it
officer please shut the [ __ ] up and get
out of the car i was pissed
he pissed me the [ __ ] off the fact they
didn't find that weed in the console was
insane stupid
how amazing did it feel when you
realized i was there i was about
30 minutes after we got onto the dirt
road thing i was just randomly looking
around we're talking like don't worry
right when we get there i'm trying to
like
hype his wife up like don't worry when
we get there it's gonna be great he's
gonna
talk their ear off you know bart he's we
thought he was because we all went no
way
no way he two bits did we convinced him
because the whole time he's getting
arrested officer
officer come on please we have a
convention tomorrow we are doing like
he's
he was trying to do whatever he [ __ ]
could to get out of the situation
so about 30 minutes a night just clicked
in looked in and go guys
we were hyped as [ __ ] oh it was so good
dude
um but yeah that's the time we got
extorted by the cops what else do you
got
oh wedding ring huh nicest car i ever
seen so sleazy hollywood
huh what do you guys do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's 1960 yes
yes oh huh i see you got two brown
people in your car
that's how i felt like oh no his hat
just got scary
[Music]
okay good two hours we told ourselves
today would be
an hour and 20. it's okay it's that
story that really got us sorry guys
i know you guys want them longer but me
and i'm already trying to i did like a
half hour preparing for the next up
next episode next week too true true
well we did
it's gonna be a fun episode yeah it's a
good one that's a good one guys um
i think that's everything i had on the
list that's it yeah it is good [ __ ]
anything to add marty i don't think so
the premiere was uh went great of our
episode yesterday
[ __ ] about if you guys don't know
um if you're listening the car on
youtube on monday just like the podcast
uh
on the audio on monday on youtube the
dope is it's called dope as usual
podcast that's the youtube channel
we're live we do live live stream so
basically we premiere the video and the
video
plays the pre-recorded video plays but
on the side there's a live chat
the only thing that's live is the chat
i'm in there marty's in there
we're typing talking to fans and [ __ ] so
we watch these episodes together they
premiere
you watch it i watch it we're in the
same chat talking to each other
it's very [ __ ] cool and interactive
it's dope as [ __ ]
dope as usual podcast that's on youtube
um and the fan questions are coming from
patreon yes
the fan questions we got today are
coming from patreon guys um
so basically we just pick random random
questions of the week
every time i say what the [ __ ] was it
talking about we bring up a question so
maybe if i tighten it up
we won't be doing as many questions but
we'll figure out another way of
incorporating fans because we want to
get more
interaction with you guys you guys are
[ __ ] on it you're you're super
[ __ ] on everything on twitter on
instagram
we love stereo how that went stereo was
awesome just like i said we told you
guys before
the complications going on with that guy
passing away but you guys the fans being
able to put up questions and be there
live that was cool
that [ __ ] was scott that [ __ ] was hella
tight um i think that's it man
i think i said i think we end it or 158
damn god i feel like that story took
forever dude i'm just sitting here
playing in my head so bad
god i hate it that day um i think that's
it dude
let's uh let's end it yeah
anything else to say i don't think so
man it's going to be a big week a lot is
in the air
a lot's pending we're just we got our
heads down we're working hard we
appreciate all the support and all the
love and we're just trying to
really push up to that next level these
next two weeks or so and
it's right there it's a cool little
timer good [ __ ]
so guys what are we taking away from
this episode
sometimes you get extorted by the cops
that's my boy is a great [ __ ] movie
go watch it
adam stanley you got to watch it man
it's so good and uh
the movie profile sucked dick what else
i think that's it man i think it's it we
talked about marty's banging someone's
girlfriend and then
almost got beat up you know
he doesn't want like his kids are in the
room yeah
shut the [ __ ] up i don't know i had to
consider it it was close
it was close it was close yeah
all right so guys thank you so much for
watching this is uh
episode 16. this is a fun time this is
my favorite time of the week
this shit's tight right right when we're
about to start i get the most hyped
yeah i don't know what it is like in the
day i'm like i'm not stressing i'm just
like worried about like
all right do i have everything set up
all right i think i know what i want to
talk about oh and then i get here it's
[ __ ]
fun so thank you guys for making it fun
thanks for making uh
our job cool thank you for the numbers
for liking and
the views remember the more views and
all that the more money we can make
the easier it is in our lives for doing
the [ __ ] out of pocket because we owe
ourselves a lot of money still
for putting this together but it's a
good it's a good feeling it's [ __ ]
awesome so uh yeah marty i think that's
it
oh yeah thank you guys thank you you
guys thank you so much for watching this
has been the dope as usual podcast
this is marty drastic graphics i am
thomas dobaziola thank you guys so much
for watching
this is about uh i mean this this is
about uh
double usual podcast we're here to talk
about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between i'm so shocked i [ __ ] nailed
that right now
thank you guys so much for watching
until next week interview with the drug
dealer
thank you guys so much for watching have
no best day
nice bomb
bomb i got this weird country song stuck
in my head
not a good country song like a new
country song
what about a good
dress up
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]